Five four,
three,
two,
one.
Boom.
And we're live.
Peter Schiff.
How are you sir?
I am good.
Thanks for having me back.
Thanks for coming back.
Yeah,
it's been three years.
It has been a while.
You've grown a lot.
I'm so impressed with what's happened to
your podcast,
your popularity.
Thanks man.
Thank you.
Hopefully a little of that trickles down
to me.
I'm sure it will.
You look good dude.
You look healthy.
You look at vibrant.
Well,
you know,
I got a little bit of a beard going.
I've been living in Puerto Rico.
We were talking about that off air.
Tell me about that.
Like what,
what prompted that decision?
Well,
you know,
I live in Connecticut and unlike
southern California where you are
fortunate enough to still live,
I lived here for a long time,
years and years ago.
But uh,
we have,
uh,
seasons and uh,
one of them is winter and it tends to be
very long and it normally Kinda,
you know,
kinda moves into the fall and the spring
a bit.
And so I had been thinking for years
about kind of splitting my time between
Florida and Connecticut because I Love
New England in the summer.
It's beautiful this time of year.
Yeah.
And I like the beginning of fall,
you know,
with the leaves are still on the trees
and it's not that cold and it's pretty.
And you know,
spring is nice too.
So,
but yeah,
I can forget all the winter.
So I was going to move to Florida until
I found out about Puerto Rico.
And I found out about this actually
because I read an article interviewing
John Paulson and Halston was John Paul,
John Paulson,
billionaire hedge fund guy made a lot
more money than me shorting subprime.
I did the same trade.
I just didn't make as much money as he
did,
uh,
because I didn't start out with nearly
as much money,
but in any event,
but,
but he made a lot of money shorting
subprime and he's a hedge fund guy.
And,
um,
he was investing down in Puerto Rico and
I was like,
well,
what's he doing?
What's,
what's going on down there?
And I found out,
and I had never known this,
that Puerto Rico as a US territory,
Americans who live in Puerto Rico don't
have to pay federal income taxes on the
money they earn from Puerto Rico,
which would include any of your capital
gains on your investments.
And I'm like,
wait a minute.
I mean all I have to do is move to
Puerto Rico,
don't have to pay any federal income
taxes cause anybody can move there.
You don't need a,
a,
you know,
a work visa.
You pick up and move there.
It's just like moving to another state.
Right.
And so the minute you move there,
you don't have to pay federal income
taxes,
but Puerto Rico has its own taxes.
So you have to pay the Puerto Rico taxes
instead.
And up until recently,
I mean,
Puerto Rico's income tax,
I think tops out at 30% it's still
cheaper than the u s and there's no
state income tax.
It's,
that's all you've got,
right?
Is that the 30% but a few years ago,
Puerto Rico got smart and they said,
well,
how do we attract businessmen,
entrepreneurs to move to Puerto Rico if
they're not already here?
Well,
let's just drop that income tax down.
And so they basically created these two
laws,
act 29 22 and act 22 is for individuals.
And it says,
Hey,
if you move to Puerto Rico,
you have zero capital gains tax on any
capital gains and you have zero on any
interest in dividends that you earn
locally.
And then they passed another act,
which is at 20 and they said,
hey,
if you open up a business here,
you have a company,
you're going to pay a 4% corporate tax
to Puerto Rico,
and then you can pass on all the profits
in dividends to yourself,
tax free,
no tax in Puerto Rico,
no tax in the United States.
And you know,
that's,
that's a great deal.
That seems to be worth a tremendous
amount of money.
It is.
I mean,
it depends on,
but you effectively double your income
by moving there practically.
So,
because you're not,
you know,
you're not splitting your income with
the government.
Right.
And,
and,
and so I checked it out when I heard out
about front,
heard about,
because first it's like Puerto Rico.
Do I,
you know,
do I really want to live there?
And you know,
I'm thinking west side story.
I don't know.
But,
um,
you know,
it's beautiful.
I mean,
I live in a town called Dorado beach.
Ah,
and you know,
it's just,
it's very,
very nice.
The,
the,
uh,
the weather and just the tropical
location and there's a lot of good
people there.
A lot of people have been moving there.
Obviously I'm not the first person to
take advantage of this.
And so there are a lot of people that
have come from California to get out of,
you know,
California taxes or the northeast,
the Midwest,
you know,
plus when you come from the Midwest or
the northeast,
you also,
you know,
help yourself get out of the cold
weather,
California.
It's pretty much all a tax thing.
I mean,
no one's leaving southern California,
uh,
other than really the taxes because you
got such great weather here.
Um,
but I,
I,
we enjoy living there.
My wife enjoys it.
She's met a lot of people.
I've met a lot of people.
And you know,
the crazy thing is,
you know,
you have this movement now in Puerto
Rico where they want to become a state,
which is ridiculous because if they
became a state,
all the problems they have would be that
much worse because Puerto Rico is in
trouble today,
despite the fact that you don't have to
pay federal income taxes there.
I mean,
that what happened was the Puerto Rican
government is,
which was very socialist.
They borrowed a lot of money and they,
you know,
they,
they spend a lot of money to get
elected.
And uh,
you know,
a lot of people in Puerto Rico work for
the government and a lot of people are
on welfare,
food stamps and stuff like that.
But big government is what destroyed the
Puerto Rican economy.
And they,
and they borrowed a lot of money.
But if on top of that,
Puerto Rican residents that actually had
jobs had to pay the federal income tax,
you know,
it's not just the federal income tax
doesn't apply down there.
It's the obamacare tax.
You know,
people wanted obamacare repealed.
If you move to Puerto Rico,
you've repealed it for yourself because
the taxes don't apply down there.
They don't even have to pay the federal
gas tax.
So without all those taxes,
they're still in trouble.
So can you imagine how much worse it
would be if they had all these taxes?
If all of a sudden the irs descended on,
on Puerto Rico,
like an infestation of,
you know,
mosquitoes and be worse than the Zika
virus down there to have the irs.
Uh,
so,
but you know,
there's people,
they've told a lot of people,
hey,
if we become a state,
you'll get more welfare.
Like,
oh,
so vote to become a state.
But what Puerto Rico,
the last thing they need is a more,
more incentives to be on welfare.
Right?
They need freedom.
They need less government.
They need to default on a lot of this
debt.
And a lot of the people that own the
bonds unfortunately have to lose some
money.
But I think that as more and more people
move to Puerto Rico,
I've got two businesses down there now.
I'm hiring people,
I'm renting space.
I bought a lot of property down there.
You know,
more and more people like me as people
come to Puerto Rico,
the economy's going to improve,
it's going to get better.
Uh,
but if they become a state,
they're going to destroy all that
potential.
They,
they have to exploit the fact that
Puerto Rico can offer such a great
advantage to a businessman.
Somebody he wants to create a company,
employee,
people provide goods and services.
They can do it in Puerto Rico.
I know on a,
on a much favorable,
uh,
basis relative to anywhere in the
continental United States.
So this is a recent thing for you.
How long have you been down there for?
Well,
I moved by asset management company.
So I have a company called Euro Pacific
asset management.
And I moved that company from southern
California.
I was based in Newport beach with that
business and I moved to San Juan I think
in 2013 and then I moved to Toronto.
So I have my office there and I moved
all my portfolio managers,
they all moved from California to Puerto
Rico.
That's going to be a tough sell.
You know,
they love it down there.
But was it difficult to convince people
to pack up to which essentially another
country?
It's not really,
but it kind of it it's America.
But yeah,
technically it's not like that kind of a
situation.
Yeah,
well it's the same status,
but I've never been to Guam.
But I mean you do feel,
it does feel a little bit like a foreign
country when,
because English is the second language.
Everybody is speaking Spanish.
So in a way,
you know,
but all you look around,
it's all the same restaurants.
It's all the same stores.
So it's American in,
in
all the malls,
you know,
the same malls.
And so there's a lot of ex,
not really ex pats because they were
actually still in America.
Yeah.
You do not renounce your citizenship
when you move to Puerto Rico.
You do not have to pay an exit tax.
I you still travel on on an on a US
passport.
Everybody that lives there is an
American.
So it's like a sweeter deal than moving
to Hawaii.
Well Hawaii you got high taxes,
you're still paying federal income
taxes.
Paradise.
Yeah.
Plus you're paying the state income
taxes in Hawaii.
So,
but you know,
my guys wanted to move there cause it
basically almost meant that their income
was going to double like pretty much
overnight cause they can participate in
these tax breaks.
But you know,
my,
one of my guys is married,
has some kids and you know,
they really like it.
My single employees,
I have a few young guys you know,
you know,
good shape working out,
young portfolio managers but they've,
you know,
they quickly got Puerto Rican
girlfriends.
You know,
if you've got a job down there that's a
big plus because most of the Puerto
Rican guys and out of you know this,
but I think five of the miss universes
of kind of Puerto Rico.
I mean it's,
it's a small little island country,
but they got some beautiful women down
there in Puerto Rico.
It sounds like you're a salesperson for
Puerto Rico a lot.
I should.
I've said so many people down there.
A lot of people have moved there because
to me,
I run into people all the time.
They see me on the beach.
You have to Hell Pete.
You know that you're the reason that I'm
here because they heard about it.
But,
but look,
it's a,
it's a good deal.
And you know,
I would love to see Puerto Rico succeed
as a mecca of free market capitalism
right now.
You know,
it's a poster child for the failures of
socialism because they,
it's the socialist that killed Puerto
Rico,
just like they're killing a lot of major
cities in the United States.
But if we get more entrepreneurs,
more business people are coming to
Puerto Rico,
you know,
that is what Puerto Rico needs.
They don't need to be a state,
they don't need the irs.
They don't need more government.
They need the opposite of that.
So you learn in Spanish or are you just
sort of standing around?
Well,
I mean,
we're doing it.
They're all Americans.
Americans.
But I mean,
I speak English.
I mean,
I,
I took high school Spanish,
so you know,
if I go through a dry through,
you know,
I got to try to use my Spanish because a
lot of times they don't speak.
But,
um,
and no one,
if you talk to someone from the police
or the fire department of those guys
speak any English.
But most of the younger people,
they've learned English.
And where I live,
it's everybody speaks English.
I mean,
nobody addresses me once I get out of
the gates of the rich,
you know,
Rich Carlton,
I go out into a movie theater,
they're,
you know,
they're speaking Spanish.
And then if I say,
do you speak English,
then they'll talk.
But where I live,
everybody addresses everybody in
English.
So in that respect,
you know,
you're still there.
So you live in like a gated area that's
a part of the Ritz Carlton.
Yeah,
it's a gated community,
but it's very large.
You know,
we have a lot of golf course,
so I think three or four golf courses
were on the beach and there's,
you know,
a lot of different places to live there.
Any resentment from the locals?
Not that I can feel.
I mean,
because I mean,
I know some of the locals could feel,
hey,
these guys are coming in here.
They're not paying a lot of taxes,
but I pay a lot of taxes as a,
just a raw number.
It's not a big percentage of what I
earn,
but it's a big number relative to what
other people might be paying.
But you know,
I'm doing all,
I'm hiring people.
As I said,
I rented office space.
I mean I bought a house,
I bought a condo.
I'm going out.
So I mean they benefit,
they like having,
if you're,
if you like having people doing stuff
and in,
so I don't,
I don't,
I don't see it at all.
Now if it becomes a state status,
if it changes status,
will you move?
I don't know.
We'll see.
I might have to,
I mean,
it might not.
it won't be nearly as lucrative and see,
here's going to be the problem.
If they ever became a state,
see people that live there pay a 30%
income tax.
Now you know,
for to,
not,
not people like me,
but the people that were already there.
So it kind of like in California you
have 10 13% income tax.
But imagine if you had to pay a 30%
local tax and the federal income tax on
top of that.
I mean they have a 13% sales tax now,
if they have a higher sales tax.
So they have,
if they became a state,
they would be by far the highest tax
state in the United States.
They mean a disaster.
Right now they have the lowest taxes in
the United States.
So why would you want to go from having
the lowest taxes to having the highest
taxes?
It's,
it'd be,
it'd be suicide to become a state.
Yeah.
So they would have their local taxes and
then on top of that they would have
federal taxes.
Local taxes are fairly high in terms of
like a local state.
Yes.
As much higher.
Right?
But
then on top of that,
they don't have federal taxes.
Right.
And you know,
the other thing is Puerto Rico has a lot
of debt.
I mentioned that,
right?
But on a per capita basis,
they actually have a lot less debt than
America does.
I mean,
your share of the national debt right,
is much bigger than the average Puerto
Rican share of the Puerto Rico debt.
Because when you live in California,
not only are you responsible for the
state's debt,
you're responsible for the national
debt.
The people in Puerto Rico,
I'm not responsible for the national
debt.
So if they actually became a state,
they would be in worse shape than they
are now.
They would actually have more debt.
Right.
So it's like it'd be like buying a
ticket on the titanic after you've
already,
you know,
it hit the iceberg yet you still want to
buy tickets.
So hopefully this is all a bunch of
politics and it won't become,
it won't become a state and it'll just
continue,
you know,
they'll default on a lot of this debt.
Hopefully they'll prioritize a lot of
things.
Uh,
they'll shrink the government and more
and more people like me will come in and
start creating businesses and hiring
people and you know,
five to 10 years from now,
maybe you'll be the wealthiest part of
the united,
so correct me if I'm wrong,
but the two possibilities are,
it becomes a state and they get more
welfare.
They get more essentially more aid,
more money.
Yes.
Or it stays where it is and more people
like you have an incentive to go there
and then entrepreneurs open a businesses
and then there's more opportunities and
then the general wealth of the island
grows and that it helps people just by
virtue of more.
Yeah,
you got it.
Becoming a state just means a bigger
welfare state.
It means a greater incentive not to work
and a bigger punishment if you work
because the taxes on people,
that work will go sky high,
you know?
So that's going to be a huge problem if
you know.
So good.
The problem that the appeal of being a
state is that so many people don't work.
But you know,
one thing that we could do to help
Puerto Rico is get rid of the minimum
wage because they're stuck with our
minimum wage,
which is a disaster because the average
income,
the average wage in Puerto Rico is about
half of what it is in the United States.
And so the minimum wage of seven 25 is
like having a minimum wage of $15 an
hour.
And if you're one of those people that
likes a $15 minimum wage,
look at how high the unemployment is
down there because you can't,
you know,
you people can't get jobs at,
at these,
at these wages.
You know,
the best example too of America
destroying one of it's a possessions
with the minimum wage was American
Samoa.
I don't know if you've ever read this,
but a few years ago,
uh,
Congress applied the minimum wage to all
the territories are minimum wage,
which included American Samoa and in
American Samoa,
the biggest employers on the island
where these tuna canners and so chicken,
you know,
chicken of the sea or star cast.
And so all these people worked in these
factories canning the tuna and they
worked in,
in,
um,
in American Samoa.
Well,
when the mirror and minimum wage was
passed it,
it made the island uncompetitive.
And so the tuna factories closed down
and fired everybody.
And so all of a sudden there was like
30% unemployment.
The island went into a massive
depression and they still haven't come
out of it.
I mean,
we destroyed them,
we destroyed all their jobs.
And the,
the,
you know,
the American Samoa didn't want the
minimum wage,
but you know,
American politicians don't give a damn
and all they care about is feeling good
about themselves,
not about the consequences of what they
do.
And so they,
you know,
they,
they impose that minimum wage and it was
like declaring war.
Well,
it had a lot of damage in Puerto Rico,
just not as much as it did in American
Samoa.
But if we can get rid of that minimum
wage in Puerto Rico,
then there'd be a lot more employment
opportunities for younger,
unskilled people.
They'd have the opportunity to climb up
the job ladder to get some skills so
they can earn more money in the future.
But right now they're just permanently
unemployed.
Uh,
because of that,
so we could get rid of the minimum wage.
Also,
there's the Jones Act,
which has really,
really hurts Puerto Rico.
And what that Jones Act that says is
that any ship,
right.
And that that's going to America.
They can't stop in Puerto Rico,
drop a few things off,
and then continue on to the United
States.
They have to,
they have to go all the way to the
United States,
unload their cargo,
that's going to Puerto Rico,
put it on a US flag ship with a u s
crew,
and then send it back to Puerto Rico.
And it costs a fortune.
Right.
So that's one of the reasons that their
tourism is not that competitive there.
Because all the other Caribbean islands
can get cheap stuff dropped off on
boats.
But you know,
we have to wait for stuff to come on a
Jones act boat.
And so it,
what was the incentive to pass the Jones
act?
It's for the unions,
the Maritime Union,
the merchant marine to try to,
because you know American ships are
uncompetitive.
Like if you ever go on a cruise on,
if you go on a cruise,
but none of these cruise ships are
flagged in the United States and none of
the crews are American.
That's because if you had to use an
American crew with our laws,
nobody could afford to cruise.
It would be too expensive.
The only way that you can have a cruise
line that anybody can afford the travel
on is if you flag it in some other
country.
Well,
so because the wages are just off the
charts,
but that Jones act means if people in
Puerto Rico,
you know,
whatever they're going to buy,
whatever they're going to consume in
order to bring it to that island,
you know,
they're going to have to bring it on a,
on a US flag ship.
Now it that,
that's a problem for Hawaii too.
But the people in Hawaii are much richer
on average and the people in Puerto
Rico,
so the poor you are,
the more you're affected by,
by higher food costs are higher,
you know,
costs of everything.
So it's,
you know,
you have a lot of these,
liberal politicians,
they refuse to get rid of these laws.
But that would,
would very much help Puerto Rico just
more free markets cause they,
they have no control over that federal
minimum wage where the or that Jones
Act.
So you don't think there should be any
minimum wage at all?
No,
no,
no.
None boat.
So someone working for a dollar an hour,
it doesn't bother you.
Well,
I mean it's better than working for
zero.
I mean,
people think that,
um,
you know,
they,
they want to impose their morals and
say,
well,
it's not right for somebody to work for
a dollar an hour.
Well,
you know,
people make rational decisions,
right?
And so somebody
is accepting a dollar an hour and that
must mean that nobody offered them a
dollar 50.
Nobody offered them $2.
I mean,
this is a competitive,
a market.
I mean,
I know you have an employee over here.
could you pay this guy a dollar an hour
when he worked for you?
I don't think so.
Yeah.
Well a got,
because he could get more.
Right.
But he's,
he's educated and skilled and he's an
engineer and of course,
right.
But it's very difficult for people to
get that sort of an education,
particularly in wwe is Puerto Rico
thought of as a third world environment
and so country third world.
But let's say some kid came in here that
had no experience whatsoever,
but he wanted to learn.
He wanted to just get you coffee and
just sit around and be around you.
He's not that productive.
Yeah.
They use the interns,
right?
A lot of radio stations do that and they
don't pay them anything.
I know that $0 million and I can't do
that.
Well then yeah,
but maybe you pay him $5 now,
whatever it is,
but people,
people are going to accept a job.
That's the best one they can get,
and so if somebody is working for a
dollar an hour or $2 an hour,
by default,
I know that they couldn't find a higher
job than that.
And the reason is because they don't
have a lot of skills.
But if you don't have a lot of skills,
the best thing you can do is get a job
so you can get some skills.
That's where you learn skills,
you get more skills.
You know there are people that pay to
get skills,
right?
If you go to school,
you actually have to pay tuition.
If I'm getting paid a dollar an hour
while I learned something that has
value,
that's better.
You have people now borrowing money to
learn a skill.
People Graduate College and they're in
debt,
right?
It's not a weird,
that's a weird argument,
right?
Because you're assuming that they're
going to get a skill.
I mean,
they might just be handling packages and
picking them up and moving to another
location.
That's a whole or well,
even that's like show up on time,
be responsible.
So disciplines and showed a lot of work.
There's a lot of stuff that you learn
when you have a job,
but the problem with the minimum wage is
that the minimum wage basically hurts
the very people that it's intended to
help because the minimum wage basically
says if you are a worker,
if you cannot convince an employer to
pay you seven 25 or $10 an hour,
whatever the minimum wage,
then you cannot accept that job.
See,
it doesn't hurt the employer.
It hurts the employee because it limits
his options.
It limits his ability to sell his Labor,
uh,
for the highest price that he can get.
And it limits his access to the job
market.
It's a,
you know,
you can't get on that ladder.
You,
you know,
you remove the lower rungs.
And so I can't climb up because of this
arbitrary minimum wage.
Uh,
because when you pass a minimum wage,
you're not going to force an employer,
right?
If I'm an employer and there's a minimum
wage of $10 an hour and somebody comes
to me and they can deliver $5 an hour
worth of productivity,
meaning if I hire that person that will
benefit me by $5 an hour,
I'm not going to pay them $10 an hour
because then I lose $5 an hour.
The only way I'm going to hire somebody
who's going to give me $5 an hour worth
of productivity is if I can buy them.
If I can,
you know,
hire him for less than $5 an hour so I
can make a profit.
So it just,
it sits like a floor.
It's like if you cannot deliver enough
productivity of whatever that minimum
wages,
then you can't get a job.
And so it's basically making it illegal
for people to work.
It is the stupidest law that anybody has
ever conceived.
A,
it should be obliterated.
I mean,
there are some countries,
like Singapore does not have a minimum
wage.
And you know,
the average income in Singapore is
higher than it is here per capita.
There's a lot more millionaires there.
I mean,
people have no problem.
We didn't always have a minimum wage in
the United States.
I mean,
this is a creation of government and you
know,
but the,
the initial minimum wages,
if you want to actually go to the
origins of minimum wage in the United
States,
it was about trying to prevent employers
from hiring the Chinese or hiring
blacks.
They were trying to force them in ways
as a way to create unemployment.
It wasn't,
there wasn't a,
a good motivation.
But yes,
when they try to sell it to the voters,
oh,
it was all about,
we don't want people to be exploited,
but you know,
it's not exploitation of people
voluntarily accept the job because it's
the best job they can find.
The person who's offering the best job
is not exploiting them.
They're giving them an opportunity.
And if you're denied an opportunity,
I mean,
there are a lot of people,
oh great.
You know they're going to get the
minimum wage up to $15 an hour.
Well,
what good is it being unemployed at $15
an hour?
It's better to be employed at $5 an hour
than unemployed at 15 because being
unemployed means you make nothing.
Right.
We're devil's advocate would be that if
you can't afford to pay someone $15 an
hour,
then you probably shouldn't have
employees in the first place.
Your Business doesn't function that
well.
No,
there are plenty of sense.
because there are plenty of jobs where
you have entry level positions.
I mean,
if you think that there should be no
entry level jobs,
I mean you go back to the days of a full
service gas stations right?
Back in the day when you know you didn't
have to pump your own gas till the case
in New Jersey and a few other states,
New Jersey,
you know,
they mandate it,
but you still don't get the level of
service.
I mean,
if you've pulled into a gas station 40
years ago,
not only did they pump your gas,
but they checked under your hood.
They,
I used to do it.
Tires,
you're,
you know,
they,
they watched your windows,
you know,
they did all sorts of things.
Uh,
you know,
with your car,
they didn't make very much money.
They lived off of tips.
By and large it was the minimum wage
that eliminated almost all those jobs.
It's a minimum wage.
That is the reason that we have,
you know,
people sell so much self serve.
But what happened,
a lot of these people,
these kids that worked in filling
stations became mechanics because all
these filling stations had a mechanic
there and they,
they learned auto mechanics and a lot of
them went on to own their own gas
stations.
But of course a lot of them,
this was their work experience that
formed the basis for the rest of their
life.
A lot of young kids had these jobs,
summer jobs.
And so there's nothing wrong with a
entry level employment.
There's nothing wrong with people
learning the responsibility of having a
job of showing up of customer service of
mean.
My first jobs were all sales.
I was selling subscriptions door to
door.
I was telephone sales of this,
the z channel and California.
I sold,
I was knocking on doors selling cable
television.
I worked in a shoe store selling shoes.
I mean,
but hustler.
But you were talking about you as a
young man,
right?
That's a lot of people think of the
minimum wage as applied to adults.
Adults that have to take care of
children,
that I have to have a roof over their
head and food on the table.
And you're saying that that,
that they shouldn't be having those
jobs.
Well by the time you are an adult with
kids,
you should have accumulated the skills
to earn a lot more than a minimum wage.
So that's the argument when people say,
Hey,
you can't afford a family.
You can't support a family on the
minimum wage.
Of course you shouldn't even be trying
to support a family if you can only earn
the minimum wage.
You shouldn't have a family.
You,
you should realize,
hey,
I can't afford a family yet.
Let me acquire the skills before I start
fathering children.
Right?
And,
and getting married,
let me make sure I can support myself.
I mean,
a lot of people who are having the
minimum wage,
they're living at home,
they're there.
They,
you know,
they don't need to pay the rent.
They're living rent free.
What they need is a job they need maybe
gas money,
get some money.
So I could take a girl out on a date,
but I gotta I gotta get some work
experience.
I got to get out there,
I got to know what it's like to work.
I got to see,
you know,
I've got to live in the real world and
that's what used to happen.
I mean,
you don't have all these summer jobs
anymore.
Kids don't have the opportunity because
the minimum wage has already priced them
out.
A lot of older people now we're taking
those,
those jobs and so the,
the employment opportunities aren't
there.
But when you just raised the in wage,
all you're doing is raising the bar
where you can get your job.
You're not helping people.
Now,
there is always going to be some people
that,
yeah,
there's going to be somebody who will
make a little bit more because of the
minimum wage.
There's going to be those people,
there's gonna be some winners,
but you're going to have lots of people
that make nothing because of the minimum
wage.
And then of course,
because you're driving up the cost of
labor prices are going up.
And so who is affected the most by
higher prices,
poor people.
People who are working on minimum wage.
Uh,
and not only that,
you end up with less quality.
I mean,
you know,
I hate it when,
I call up a company and I'm just in
voice mail.
Hell and I'm going from one I would like
a real person to deal with.
But you know,
with the minimum wage,
those jobs don't exist.
There's so many jobs that have been
automated out of existence because not
automated shipped overseas where there
isn't any minimum that too.
I mean that too.
Yeah.
You end up,
if you actually get a real person there
in India,
right,
right.
But we have all these people in America
who aren't working,
why can't they do those jobs?
Yes.
You're not going to be able to support a
family on those jobs.
But before you even get a family,
you can have that job and then maybe you
know,
five or 10 years later you'll work your
way up the ladder,
you'll get a skill,
then you can support a family,
but nobody is supposed to be able to
support a family and if you try to tell
an employer,
hey,
you gotta,
you gotta pay your fry,
Cook enough money to support a family,
you can't do that.
There's not enough productivity cooking
French fries.
You can't support a family family.
If all you can do is cook a French fry,
you need to learn how to do something
else before you can support a family and
you can't,
you can't put that on the employer.
Now when you say that Singapore has a
higher average income is,
is that because and no minimum wage?
Is that because there's a shitload of
billionaires that have moved to
Singapore because they don't have a
minimum wage because they're getting
explore.
No lower class people or people that
don't make much money.
The millionaires and billionaires don't
eve are really not even affected by the
minimum wage.
What you'd have to look at is the rate
of unemployment rates in Singapore
sentence for very rich people to move
there.
And doesn't that Jack up the minimum
wage or not the minimum wage rather than
the average income?
Yeah.
Well the fact that you have
entrepreneurs that are succeeding in
Singapore because they have small
government and low taxes means that
there's a lot of competition for
workers.
And so that's what bids up wages,
right?
Competition.
I mean I've got no problem with a
vibrant market bidding up wages.
You just don't want the government to
try to artificially force wages above
their productivity.
Right.
Because it's ultimately your
productivity that determines your wages.
You mentioned that you know,
your,
your employee here,
he has a lot of ads,
a lot of value because of his knowledge,
because of his personal good.
Look at,
look at Samsung.
Well that doesn't,
that doesn't help me.
But uh,
but you know,
and you're like,
we're laughing.
But there are a lot of people,
look,
there are a lot of people that earn more
money because they're good to look at.
Right?
There are plenty of people that are paid
more models,
but you go to Puerto Rico and then Miss
Universe and right.
But even people hire receptionists or
people hire people in certain positions
because they look good and they get paid
a little extra for that because that's
added value to the customer experience
and things like that.
So most of us can't live off of our
looks.
We gotta,
we gotta have some something else,
but it's all a function of your
productivity.
You want to earn more,
you have to produce more.
Did government just can't mandate that
people pay you more than you're worth as
far as the productivity that you can
deliver because you're just not going to
have a job.
You're making a ton of sense.
And uh,
obviously I'm not a financial wizard
like you are.
What,
when you'd start talking about like
people making more money for their,
looks not,
that would be a hot button topic in
America and people will get very upset
about it and that people would say that
that's a sexist viewpoint and you're
objectifying these women that you have
working in these positions.
What would you say to that?
Like a secretary or someone who's a
receptionist who's super hot,
like the year you're objectifying this
woman?
Well,
you know,
there are a lot of men and women,
men get hired for their looks too.
I mean,
it's not just a one way street,
amy.
It's like you said,
but look,
you know,
people make the most of what they got
right.
I mean,
people say,
Hey,
it's not fair.
Why should this?
Well,
it's unfair to the unattractive people,
but build the unattractive person could
be really smart.
Maybe she ends up making mom and ugly.
Well look,
you know,
not everybody wins the lottery life can
have them write a little bit.
Isn't that the problem with socialism
and the idea of we should even out the
playing field?
Yes.
I mean the idea that competent and
you're a competition guy,
right?
But you know,
a famous Democrat,
John Kennedy said that life is unfair
and live in a different era,
but it's not fair.
Right.
And he's just trying to bang a lot of
checks and you can't,
you know,
you can't dwell on the things that you
don't have.
Hey,
I wish I could've been born better
looking.
I could been born tall,
taller.
You know,
you've got to make the most,
it's like playing poker.
You got hand play it,
you can have the worst hand and you can
win the pot.
Right?
So,
you know,
obviously is it easier to win the hand
if you got four lasers?
Right.
But you know what,
if you're a bad player,
you'll win nothing cause everybody's
going to drop.
Right?
And so even getting the best hand,
it doesn't necessarily mean you're
gonna,
you're gonna,
you're gonna play it.
Right.
But you know,
it's not,
I mean,
if two people,
if I want to hire somebody and the way
they look,
I believe is going to help me earn more
money because I think that having a more
attractive person and particularly
business position is going to somehow
lead to greater sales.
I mean,
that's really the only reason that
you're going to pay somebody more money
if they look good.
Like look it on,
you know,
I go on Fox television or CNBC,
it's not an accident that all these
women interviewing me are pretty hot,
right?
I mean,
unattractive women could read the news
and ask me questions just as good as
they can,
but they're hoping and they're betting
that more guys like us are going to tune
in to watch a hot chick interview me.
Then a home we won and they're probably
right,
right?
Because probably lots of homely girls
that are applying for these jobs,
they're not getting hired.
No,
I,
I agree with you 100% but there's a
fascinating thing that's going on today
where our competition is thought to be
in somehow some way,
shape or form a negative thing.
And that this kind of competition,
whether it's co,
even capitalism itself is criticized,
right?
Like there's a lot of people today that
are in favor of socialism and it's one
of the reasons why Bernie Sanders was so
attractive is because like,
Hey,
you people that are not winning this
crazy competition out there that don't
have any desire,
we're going to even out this playing
field.
And those people that are out there
kicking ass and taking names,
we're going to take some of that money
and we're going to just give it to
everybody else.
Yeah.
That is the appeal of socialism because
it appeals to the lowest common
denominator.
Downloads his appeal to ignorance,
but it appeals to greed because an envy
like,
oh,
this person has so much more than me and
it's not fair.
But here's the beauty of competition
because this is why we want competition.
We all want stuff,
right?
And and so I want people competing to
sell me stuff,
right?
I want to have as much as I can as far
as consumer goods.
That's what we all want.
We want products and services that
enhance our lives and the way we get the
best products with the highest quality
that deliver the most value at the
lowest price is to have lots of
competition.
All kinds of people competing for my
business.
Hey,
I've got some money to spend.
Oh,
buy my product,
buy my product.
Competition is what's made is what makes
sure that I get the best thing.
Right?
You go back to the old Soviet Union and
uh,
you know,
there was no competition.
Let's say you wanted a phone in the
Soviet Union in the 1960s.
Well you went on a waiting list and
maybe three or four years later,
if you were lucky enough you had the
right connections.
Somebody gave you this big fat black
phone,
you know,
and,
and you had one phone and it was very
expensive.
You know,
that's,
that's phones under co under capitalism.
Look at the phones we have,
I got a fallen and I could take movies
with it.
It's a kit.
It's a computer.
It's a camera.
I used
it to get here with its GPS.
I mean,
do you think I would have a phone like
this if the government was,
had a monopoly on phones?
Absolutely.
I had a by any government phone that
they were going to put in my place.
So we all to say the competition isn't
good.
All the things that we value wouldn't
exist if people weren't competing with
one another.
No,
I'm,
well,
I'm a big believer in competition,
but one of the weird arguments is
happening now is that competition is bad
and it's a very blinders argument.
And I,
I saw you battle against that argument
when you were with occupy Wall Street,
when you went down to the park and talk
to those people.
That's how I,
for a lot of these very aggressive,
very passionate people with a limited
amount of understanding about capitalism
itself.
They had no underst hilarious.
And it was,
it was a wonderful exposing,
but they were there,
which was weird,
right?
Well,
they were in there.
They have signs,
they're screaming,
they're yelling,
they're angry,
but yet,
yeah,
and you know,
is very little understanding of what the
system that they're rallying against.
One of the reasons I went there,
and if you haven't seen it,
you're plenty of youtube videos of it.
The law there,
there's one that's like two and a half
hours.
Right.
That's the whole,
I talked until we ran out of power.
Right.
I've seen them all,
but I seen about 10 videos of you
talking to these people,
but somebody just recently resurrected.
It,
made a copy of it and got another two
and a half million views just a few
months ago.
So I know people are watching it,
but you know,
I went down there because I sympathized
with the fact that people are upset and,
and that I know that the economy is not
as productive as it should be.
I know there's a lot of people that
don't have jobs that should have jobs.
I think that we should have a much more
vibrant economy.
We should have a much higher standard of
living.
There should be a lot more opportunity.
But it's not because we don't have
enough government is because we have too
much.
And it's the problems that we have on
Wall Street.
We're not a function of capitalism,
but a function of the government's
failure to allow capitalism.
And the reason that I was predicting the
2008 financial crisis and they were
calling me doctor doom.
The reason I,
I knew about the housing bubble in
advance and I was able to see the
financial crisis coming was because I
understood the dynamics at play.
I understood how the government,
how the Federal Reserve,
how their policies we're working to
inflate these bubbles.
And I understood the moral hazards and
the consequences of what was going on.
And so when I went down as a Cottey
Park,
the point I was trying to make,
and not even so much the people that
were protesting,
but to the people who I knew would watch
the interaction all around the world was
to make the point that you are right to
be upset,
but you're,
you're,
you're venting your anger in the wrong
direction.
They're inventing,
they're angry or people at you like you
and a successful,
the quote unquote one 1% capitalism.
And I would say,
look,
it's the Federal Reserve that is the
source of your problems.
It's congress.
It's the White House.
It's not the financial district in New
York City.
I mean the free market people in the
free market are there to help you write
anyone in anyone that has a business,
all they're trying to do is win your
business as a customer there.
They're competing to get you to buy
things and anything that you buy,
right?
If choose to buy something,
if I buy something for 20 bucks,
I must value what I'm buying more than
20 bucks or I wouldn't make the
exchange.
So to the extent that there's a business
out there trying to convince me to buy
something that I value more than money,
that's not going to hurt me.
The problem is government.
Government has power,
government has brute force.
The government can force me to do things
that I don't want to do.
The government can make my life worse.
A private business,
it's just going to make my life better,
right?
Because if they're not going to make my
life better,
I don't do business with them.
But the government is a different story.
They can pass laws,
they can pass taxes,
they can best regulations.
And as it so happens,
the laws and regulations that they're
passing are making people's lives worse.
And you know,
the problem wasn't that big banks
failed.
The problem was that they got bailed
out.
Don't blame the banks for accepting the
bail out.
I mean,
what would you do if someone offered to
bail you out?
Yeah,
you'd take the money.
The problem is the government,
the government shouldn't have had the
power to bail him out in the first place
so that the real enemy is government and
the power that government has.
We have to take that power away from
government.
And what,
when you take power away from
government,
you create freedom,
right?
That's what freedom is.
It's absence of government.
Right?
Now,
when you say the Federal Reserve and
Congress or the real issue,
what is their incentive to be that
issue?
What is their incentive to not allow the
market to thrive and to like you're
saying that they're the reason why there
aren't more opportunities and there
aren't more people working?
What?
What are,
what is,
what does,
what do they have to gain?
Well,
Paul,
what are they doing?
Politicians have power,
right?
They want the money to get elected and
they want all the perks that come with
elected office.
Uh,
most people that are in government live
pretty good lives.
There's a reason to do it right.
It's not that they want to serve the
people will help the people.
They want a personal benefit.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's all it,
that's all the nonsense,
right?
They all pretend that they're public
servants,
but that's,
that,
that's that Spiel,
right?
That they're,
they're all there.
They're,
they're acting.
they're playing a part that's a,
that's a means to an end.
They want the power.
They want the perks that come with
elected office.
And so obviously in order to get
elected,
you've got to get the votes.
You got to get the contributions.
And so they're not making policy.
That's good economics.
All they're trying to do is get elected
and get donations.
And so they have a vested interest in
helping the people that give them money.
And people are always trying to buy
special perks from government,
uh,
a tax break or you know,
put these,
you know,
regulate my competitor instead of me or
put this guy out of business.
And of course a lot of people just vote
for something for free.
That was the power of Bernie Sanders.
I'll give you free stuff,
right?
Both from me.
And there are a lot of people who don't
know any better and they're just going
to vote for whoever it promises the most
free stuff.
But free stuff isn't free.
It's very expensive.
But what it really amounts to is theft.
I mean,
the liberal say,
vote for me and I'm going to steal from
somebody else and give you what I take
because the government doesn't have
anything the government doesn't have,
you know,
if they're going to promise something,
they have to take it from somebody else.
They don't have anything.
Government
doesn't produce government just
redistributes what other people produce.
So there's always a cost.
But whenever the government does that,
when they taxed the productive people to
give money to nonproductive people,
they increased the incentive not to
produce.
And they decrease the incentive to
So all this redistribution of wealth
just means that there's a lot less
wealth to redistribute and everybody
ends up poor.
If the politicians stayed out of it,
then you'd have a lot more wealth and
everybody would be better off.
But that's not,
you know,
the politics of it are the things that
are good economics are bad politics.
Like,
like take,
take,
uh,
healthcare.
Why couldn't the Republicans Repeal
Obamacare,
right?
Because obamacare is terrible economics.
But here's the problem.
How is it terribly economics.
We're going to get into this.
The last time you were here.
Yeah,
we got sidetracked.
What,
what is terrible about it?
Well,
I mean,
I mean we could spend the whole show on
why it's bad economics,
but you know,
there's a belief out there that
government is somehow going to be a more
efficient provider of health care than
the free market,
which is just not true.
Right?
I mean,
healthcare is a surface,
right?
Just like food,
just like shelter,
just like clothing and the free market
can provide it better and cheaper than
government.
I mean,
that's just always the case.
Some people like it as a service.
So that becomes a part of what the
government offers you along with,
you know,
when you pay your taxes,
they fixed the roads,
they hire the police,
things along those lines.
They would like healthcare to be along
that line as well,
just like it is in the UK and in Canada
and,
and you know,
and in some ways those systems are
better than the system we have now,
but they're not better than the system
we used to have or better than the
system that we could have if it was a
pure free market,
you know?
But that,
that,
there's two things you got right,
you've got healthcare and then you've
got the health insurance,
right?
Let's look at those two,
those two industries separately because
the reason that people buy health
insurance,
right,
is in case,
well,
if I get really sick,
I can't afford the bills,
right?
Just like,
you know,
people buy car insurance,
right?
When you buy car insurance,
you know that you still have to pay for
gas.
You know,
you don't expect your car insurance
policy to cover the cost of gas.
It doesn't cover the cost of new tires.
It doesn't cover the cost of a new spark
plugs or your routine maintenance.
The reason you buy auto insurances,
Hey,
what if I get into a wreck and I total
my car,
I don't have the cash to buy a new one.
So people buy insurance because they're
insuring against something.
That's probably not going to happen,
right?
When you buy your auto insurance,
the anticipation is that you never put
in a claim and you're happy to never put
into a claim.
And the insurance company,
obviously it doesn't want you to put in
a claim.
They're hoping that they collect the
premiums.
And the way auto insurance works is
because most people don't put in a claim
because they don't get into an accident.
The insurance company has the money to
pay the people who do get an accident,
right.
And that's how insurance works.
But because of the government health
insurance then work that way anymore.
Right.
Because of the government and the
government's set up the system where if
I hire somebody and I pay them cash,
they have to pay income taxes on it.
If I give them health insurance instead
of cash,
it's tax free.
So a lot of people all of a sudden
wanted health insurance instead of cash
because they didn't have to pay tax on
health insurance.
And now more and more people started to
want their health insurance to cover the
equivalent of more gas in my car or a
flat tire.
And the minute you try to pay for your
routine medical costs with a third party
payer through health insurance,
you have these spiraling out of control
costs.
You know,
because if you never,
if you pulled up to a gas station,
it didn't actually pay for the gas.
You just like put your,
your gas,
your credit,
you're a insurance card into the pump
and they didn't even have prices.
Because when you go to the doctor,
you don't even know what things cost.
There's no prices.
I mean,
when you go to buy gas,
everybody has the price right up there.
And I look around and if one place is 2
cents cheaper,
that's where I'm going.
Right?
So,
but if,
if the gas stations didn't even bother
to put the price,
and I said,
what do you care what the gas costs?
The insurance companies paid for it,
right?
I mean,
that's what we have with the healthcare
system.
We have a system that government created
where people rely on health insurance to
pay for everything.
Health insurance should just be for very
expensive things that are probably not
going to happen to you,
right?
I,
I get hit by a car,
I get cancer.
You shouldn't use your health insurance
every time you go to the doctor.
And if we got,
if we got people to pay for their health
insurance,
the way they pay for their,
their,
their auto insurance or the life
insurance,
if we separate health insurance from
employment,
health insurance will be much cheaper.
You know,
it's the government that married the
two,
right?
And that's why people say,
well,
if you lose your job,
you lose your healthcare.
That's because the government fix the
tax code.
And people,
you know,
you don't lose your auto insurance when
you lose your job.
But the other important thing,
and here's why obamacare doesn't work.
See the thesis of Obamacare was,
Hey,
let's make it so that insurance
companies can't discriminate against
people that have a preexisting
condition,
right?
So they can't charge people more money
just because they happen to be sick.
Right?
This was one of the appeals of it.
Now,
here's the problem with that.
The only reason people buy insurance
when they're healthy health insurance is
because they know they can't buy it when
they're sick.
Like let's say with the auto insurance,
if there was a law that said that,
or auto insurance companies couldn't
discriminate based on preexisting
conditions.
If you can buy the policy after your
accident and get coverage for the same
price as if you bought it before,
right?
Nobody would buy auto insurance.
You would just wait until you had an
accident.
Auto Insurance,
a weird argument because auto insurance
is mandatory.
Like you have to have it where health
insurance not mandatory.
Well it's obamacare kind of makes it
mandatory,
right?
You're just saying it's mentoring for
the wrong aspects of Eve insurance that
it covers the wrong things.
Well even look,
fire insurance isn't mandatory either.
Oh No.
Insurance is in certain states it is and
of course not all coverages mandatory
and you know you haven't pulsory
coverage.
You have to have some which is similar
to what you're talking about with health
insurance.
Compulsory health insurance,
like for catastrophic injuries.
Well they made it,
they obamacare made it compulsory gives.
The point is this that if auto insurance
was not compulsory,
right and you can just decide whether or
not you wanted it.
If there was a law that said that
insurance companies couldn't
discriminate,
nobody would buy it because you would
just wait until after you had an
accident.
But the problem is not just that.
Well the reason why auto insurance is a
bad example is because you are going to
hit my car and you going to do damage to
me.
Have you have no insurance on your car.
I'm not going to be you run into you on
the street and collide with my body and
hurt you.
I somehow now I don't have health
insurance and so you get injured from
me.
I look,
just don't you think that's a different
argument rather than even make that
argument,
let's just go to fire insurance cause
there's only one person involved me.
So I have a house.
You know,
would I buy fire insurance if I can go
to an insurance company after my house
already burns down and by the policy for
the same price?
So the reason that people buy fire
insurance policies before their house
burns down is because they know that
nobody will sell them a policy after it
burns down.
And the insurance companies couldn't
stay in business if the only people who
were buying policies where people whose
houses already burnt down.
I agree with you.
So here's what happened with obamacare.
So Obama says we're gonna make it.
So insurance companies can't
discriminate against people who are
sick.
Well,
the result of that is no healthy
person's going to want to buy insurance.
It's a waste of money.
Why pay premiums when you're not sick?
Wait until you get sick.
So what am I can't discriminate against
you because you have a preexisting
condition.
So the way Obama tried to combat that
was,
okay,
we're going to force people to buy
insurance.
We're going to,
we're going to require employers to
provide it.
And if you know you don't get it from
your employer,
we're going to find you.
You're going to have a penalty if you
don't buy the insurance right now.
Two things about that.
One,
the penalties were too low,
right?
Because the penalty for not buying
insurance is so cheap that it's cheaper
to not buy insurance,
pay the penalty,
and then wait until you get sick to by
the insurance.
That's why the insurance companies are
losing all this money,
and that's why premiums are skyrocketing
because nobody wants to buy because the
punished if the penalties were too low.
But politically,
everybody likes the idea that insurance
companies can't discriminate based on
preclinical.
So what the Republicans tried to do was
have their cake and eat it too.
They said to the voters,
we're going to keep the ban on
preexisting conditions,
but we're going to get rid of the
mandates.
We're going to get rid of the penalties.
We're going to get rid of this.
You can't do that.
You have to have both.
The real problem was the taxes were too,
the penalties were too low.
They needed the jack those penalties up
because so many people were paying the
penalty and not buying the insurance.
But the reality is we need a free market
insurance because the Republicans want
to say you should be able to buy the
type of coverage that you want.
You should be
able to buy the kind of inch,
which is true,
but then insurance companies have to be
able to deny you coverage.
If they don't want to cover you,
they have to be able to charge you more
if you're already sick.
I mean the only way to have inexpensive
insurance is for the insurance companies
to discriminate and to charge people
more money if they're already sick.
And it's because of that.
That's why healthy people buy policies
because they know,
hey,
let me buy it now why I'm healthy,
because if I happen to get sick and it's
going to be a lot more expensive.
So what the,
what the government is trying to do is
just trying to destroy the market for
health insurance.
Meanwhile,
the costs are skyrocketing,
insurance is getting more expensive.
Healthcare is getting more expensive.
If you go back to the days before the
government was involved,
uh,
healthcare was not a problem.
It wasn't expensive.
You know,
in the 1920s,
1930 [inaudible] 1940 [inaudible] 1950s,
healthcare was not expensive.
People didn't worry about medical bills.
They were not high.
If you needed a catastrophic insurance,
it was inexpensive.
If you had to go to the doctor,
it wasn't expensive.
You know,
people didn't even worry about it
because it was cool or is quality care
and it was at a low cost.
And with all the advancements that we've
had in medicine,
with all the technology,
with all the drugs that are here,
healthcare should be cheaper today than
it was in 1940 [inaudible] and 1950s on
a,
on a real basis.
You know,
and I hear all the time people make the
argument,
well,
the reason that healthcare is more
expensive because it's more complicated
now because we do all these things that
we didn't do well.
If that were true,
then why isn't my cell phone today more
expensive than a cell phone 10 or 20
years ago?
Is it as does more expensive?
No,
it's certainly ends.
It's just you get subsidized by your,
your company,
no matter who you are,
the they,
they drag out the payments.
They like,
if you buy a cell phone from verizon,
they're not selling you the full.
Like if you buy an iphone seven they're
not selling it to you at the full rate.
The full rate would be like 1,012
hundred bucks.
Yes.
But I paid $1,000 in the 1980s for my
first cell phone that didn't do jack
compared with this very early days of
Gordon Gekko ones.
I've got this Mac Mac book air in front
of me here.
And so this back book air,
obviously this is a a,
you know,
cost me like 12 1400 bucks.
My first computer that I had in college
was an apple,
two e and that computer and I got a dot
matrix printer and I had a floppy disk
and my dad spent almost $5,000 on it in
1981 and all it was was a glorified word
processor,
right?
So obviously the power in this computer
is so much greater than the one that I
had in that apple two e yet it's less
expensive.
Even forgetting about adjusting for
inflation,
it's actually cheaper in actual dollars
and did,
despite the fact that it's more
complicated.
And my point is that just because
something is more complicated and more
doesn't mean it's going to be more
expensive.
Healthcare today should be cheaper.
All of this,
all of the new technology be bringing
down
the cost of medicine.
The reason it's not is because of
government's involvement.
Cause if government was involved in the
computer industry the same way it's
involved in healthcare,
then we would see skyrocketing computer
prices that,
you know,
okay,
so now why does the government,
and you're saying that the government
wants to destroy the insurance industry,
that they don't want to,
not adroit as troy,
but what,
why do they want to complicate it the
way I do think?
Well,
first of all,
I don't think they're smart enough to
destroy it on purpose.
I mean,
it's just the unintended consequences.
They're trying to get votes,
they're trying to get elected.
And of course,
you know,
people want something for nothing.
So number one,
you know,
you get a lot of votes by promising free
healthcare,
right?
So number one,
but also why do the insurance companies,
because there are massive subsidies for
insurance companies,
right?
If I can get the government to require
people to buy my product,
then I don't have to offer a good
product.
Right?
I mean,
when she,
wouldn't you like to government to
require everybody to listen to the Joe
Rogan podcast?
If that was mandatory,
super furious at me.
Well,
it's exactly the way it is,
but although,
but you know,
but there are a lot of businesses rather
than having to win.
Well maybe if you had a lousy podcasts
that nobody listened to,
you'd want the government to say,
Hey,
too many people are listening to Joe
Rogan forced them to listen to my
podcast instead.
So,
you know,
you have these big healthcare companies
or insurance companies that want
something from government.
They want the government to mandate
people buy their product or protect them
from competition.
No,
you can't.
If you wanted to buy an insurance policy
from a Japanese company or a Swiss
company,
you can't do it.
They can't.
Some Swiss company can't come over here
to California.
Hell,
they won't even let companies from other
states sell you policies.
I mean,
why is that?
We need more competition.
But government is protecting companies
from having to compete with one another
so they don't have to do as good a job.
But Obama was already in office,
right when he was trying to do this.
Well,
what was the incentive for trying to
pass this once he's already an office,
a wants to get reelected,
which he did.
He did get reelected,
but there's a lot of political pay off.
You have to,
you know,
pay off the people that help put you in
office and you know,
he wants to help other Democrats get
elected,
you know,
and,
and maintain,
maintain that power.
But nobody ever debate this with him in
this sort of a rational,
pragmatic way.
The way you're laying it out right now,
I have no idea.
You know,
and you don't know when it comes to a
politician,
you don't know if they're doing stupid
things because they're stupid or because
they don't care that they're done.
They're just the ramifications of what
they're trying to propose and why,
as I said,
either either that people believe in
liberal philosophy or these programs,
either because they're ignorant or
because they have an ulterior motive
right there.
There are probably some politicians
there that are actually dumb enough to
think that this is a good idea,
right?
Like we talked about the minimum wage.
There are some people that actually
believe that it's a good thing,
right?
They don't know how bad it is,
but they're doing it because they're,
they're thinking with their hearts and
not with their heads,
but there are probably some people who
support the minimum wage knowing that
it's bad,
but they know it's good politics or
they're afraid to come out against it
because that's such bad politics.
So you don't for sure.
If somebody is in favor of something,
do they actually realize how bad it is?
Right,
and they're doing it anyway.
Are they just dumb enough to actually
believe it?
I have to say if you adjust for
inflation,
you're probably right about cell phones.
So I'm thinking now like a Motorola
startac.
Oh yeah.
How much were those?
Those were expensive.
How much were they when they came out?
I think there were like five or 600
bucks,
but if you adjust for inflation about
how much it costs to use them,
that's the big one.
The roaming costs were extraordinary,
but even if you didn't roam I distance
and long distance.
My first plan,
I think when I was in,
I had my first phone and I think it was
like 70 80 bucks a month.
And I had like a half hour of talk time.
Right.
So I would,
if someone called me on my cell phone,
I was quick because I had to quickly get
off because if you went over your
minutes,
you know,
now I have unlimited,
not only is it unlimited,
I can talk,
I get,
I can see people,
I see their faces,
I could talk to people in other
countries.
Now there's companies that are offering
unlimited data too,
just cause there,
because we didn't even have database
keating.
Yes.
Because there can be,
okay.
It was 1000 bucks.
Oh,
so wrong.
See,
especially if you adjust for inflation.
Oh yeah.
And then just reinflation of a startac
phone,
which was a piece of shit comparatively.
It was amazing at the time.
And the battery lasted like a half an
hour,
45 minutes of,
you know,
and so a brand new iphone,
it's probably like 1200 so yeah,
you adjust for inflation.
You right?
Now,
when you're talking about Bernie Sanders
and you're talking about some of the
policies that that guy was proposing and
some of this,
the idea of,
you know,
Robin hooding the whole deal taking from
the rich and giving to the poor,
that's extremely appealing to people,
right?
How do you,
how do you lay it out to people in a way
that they can understand that although
this looks like a great idea,
that this is not a good idea and
ultimately it's not going to benefit
you.
It's going to make things stagnant.
It's gonna make things harder for
business and it's gonna make things
harder for jobs.
A lot of people listening right now to
even me saying that they're tweeting me
to get mad.
You fucking a shill.
You sell out you 1% or you piece of
shit.
I,
that's the thought process between Eh,
behind anybody who says anything even
remotely negative about socialism,
that you have to be some sort of a
sellout or you just want to keep things
the way they are so that you can
benefit.
And it's amazing that so many people
find socialism appealing.
Yet they'll say,
Oh,
you know,
fascism is really bad.
Right?
The Nazis were really bad.
They don't realize that the Nazi party
that stands for national socialism,
that's what it was.
It's national social.
So socialism is a broader economic
theory that encompasses cat,
uh,
communism and fascism.
They're both forms of socialism.
So,
you know,
yeah,
it's all bad.
Right?
And the whole idea,
the,
all the whole premise of socialism is
bad.
It,
you know,
it,
the free market being a libertarian is
all about the individual.
It's about freedom and,
and,
and recognizing the value of,
of the individual and their rights to
pursue their own self interest or own
happiness property.
But in,
in your question,
how do you talk to people and get them
to see how bad socialism is?
I mean,
first of all,
look at the countries that have tried it
in its extreme form,
right?
Whether it was like the Soviet Union or
a North Korea or Cuba or East Germany,
you could look at examples where you had
people moving in this direction.
These promises of,
you know,
from each,
according to his ability to each
according to his need and it was a
disaster.
So it's not like we don't have a long
history of failed socialist experiments.
And you know,
you can look at the countries that are
the most prosperous and those are the
countries that have the least amount of
socialism.
I mean,
obviously,
you know,
socialism is going to exist in a certain
degree.
It's hard to find any place on the earth
now where there isn't some elements of
socialism that have crept into the
economy.
But the extent that countries have
managed to limit the amount of socialist
policies they have,
they have maximized the standard of
living of their people.
So the more like look at Venezuela,
right?
I mean people,
you know,
and I,
I uh,
and president,
um,
uh,
trump was tweeting out not too long ago.
Oh,
you know,
he's,
he's upset that they don't have enough
democracy.
We need more democracy.
They don't need more democracy.
Democracy is what got them into trouble
because they voted for socialists.
What they need in Venezuela is more
capitalism.
They need more freedom,
not just more people voting for other
socialists.
Notice of the appeal of socialism.
Essentially the same appeal of turning
Puerto Rico into a state that you're
going to get something for it.
It's going to benefit the people.
Yeah,
I mean people,
you know,
like the idea of getting something for
nothing.
And you know,
there is a certain,
if you think of that superficially,
and that's why you know there's an old
expression,
right?
If you're not socialists by the time
you're 20 you don't have a heart.
But if you're not a concern,
by the time you're 30 you don't have a
brain.
It's because people are caring.
I mean,
in general,
most people care about their fellow
human beings,
including conservatives and
libertarians.
I mean they care to just at.
A lot of liberals think that
conservatives are mean because they
don't support these programs.
It's not because they're mean,
it's just that they recognize the
unintended consequences of these
programs,
that the programs actually make it worse
for the people that you're trying to
help.
But younger people who don't have as
much real world experience,
they don't know any better.
So it's very easy to be a socialist when
you're 16 1718 you'd never had a job.
You've never run a company,
you don't have much real world
experience,
but you're carrying human being.
So I don't fault young people for being
socialists,
but I do.
But when you get to your thirties and
your forties and you haven't grown up,
to me that's like a little kid still
believing in Santa Claus.
Right.
How come you didn't learn anything?
Here's Bernie Sanders.
He's like,
you know what is he 70 something years
old and he's,
he thinks like as a teenager,
I mean he didn't learn anything from all
this life experience.
You know,
he's,
he it,
he didn't get any smarter because it
doesn't need to have a bunch of houses.
I think Bernie owns a few houses.
Yeah,
I think he does.
And didn't mean one of the,
he's in hot water right now because his
wife,
yes.
Why she decided to go full on
capitalists for this small college and
buy up a bunch of land.
And the,
the company went bankrupt.
Yup.
The college,
which is essentially company,
right?
The way that you can get young people to
understand,
look,
most people,
even if they're not in the 1%,
they want to get to the 1% right.
Every body.
Some people would say that's not true.
Some people would say,
no,
that's not what I want.
I want to be comfortable and I want to
pursue whatever my interests are.
Why?
But what,
and again,
and what are those interests?
I mean people and be their art.
Maybe it's,
yeah,
but they still have to eat.
They still have,
they still need clothes.
So we just wanted to be comfortable.
They don't necessarily want to be a
white person,
but you're going to get those things
better from the free market.
The free market is going to make you
more comfortable than a government
program.
And if you're just trying to have a
shortcut and say,
look,
you know,
just steal some money from that rich
person and give it to me.
But most people even don't just want to
squeak by.
I mean most people want to achieve
something.
They want to strive to get the most they
can out of life.
And you know,
you know,
if you want to get a job,
I mean somebody has to hire you,
somebody has to have the capital,
somebody has to be able to pay you,
right?
You,
you're not going to get a job from a
poor person.
Right.
They don't have anything to offer.
They don't have capital to give you.
They can't pay,
you know,
write a paycheck.
You know,
so people understand,
hey,
I got my first job from somebody in the
1%.
Okay.
You know,
and now I'm,
I'm in the 1% myself because I,
you know,
I was able to gain some experience,
gain some knowledge,
you know,
so you could talk to younger people and
really show them the different,
a different path.
One is,
you know,
relying on government and thievery.
Cause that's really,
you know,
most people would agree that theft is
wrong,
right?
If the two of us got together and beat
you up,
although obviously we can't,
but as soon as we could,
we beat you up.
And we took your money.
You would say that's wrong,
right?
You can't do that.
Well,
if we got together and voted for
congressman to take your money,
you know,
we outvoted you two to one.
Why is that any any better?
I mean,
why is it okay to steal through the
ballot box,
but it's not okay to do it directly.
So the argument against that would be
that it's not stealing,
that you're just creating policies that
even the playing field and that stealing
people that are in the 1% like these
hedge fund dudes that have these giant
houses in the Hamptons,
they've accumulated massive amounts of
wealth and they're using that to
influence politicians and change laws
and they shouldn't be able to use it to
influence politicians.
That's why we have to take the influence
away from politicians,
take away that power.
But there is a wealthy hedge fund guy.
That doesn't mean I have the right to go
steal his Maserati just because he's
rich and I don't have the right to tax
him to take that maserati either.
It's,
it's just another form of theft.
When you believe in the free market,
libertarian,
you know you're giving somebody that I
did.
Look,
you don't have to get rich by stealing
with somebody else has.
You can do it on your own and you know
you,
you can benefit from what other people
have because the only way people get
rich and a free market is by delivering
service is that other people value.
The only exception is if you get rich
through government connections.
And that is not a fault of capitalism.
That is a fault of when you empower
government to sell favors for the
highest bidder.
That is not an indictment of capitalism.
That is socialism,
right?
And so that's what we have to stamp out.
We have to make sure that you can't
succeed by bribing a politician,
that you can't use government power to
create wealth.
That if you want to get wealthy,
you have to be wealthy as a result of
voluntary interactions with other human
beings without government involvement,
right?
Government is there to protect my
rights,
protect my property,
protect my life from other people who
might infringe upon my rights from
people who could steal it.
But government is not there to give you
things.
It's not there to give you a job.
It's not there to give you a health
care.
You need to earn those things on your
own.
And now obviously,
are there going to be people who are
just born,
they're just not.
They may be they have deformities or
they're not smart enough or they have
handy some kind of and they can't fend
for themselves.
Yes,
I recognize that,
but my solution for that is not to,
is not to steal from some wealthy person
and say and give the money to somebody
who needs it.
I believe in voluntary charity.
I believe that human beings care enough
about other human beings that if
somebody really is in a dire
circumstance,
that private charity,
we'll take care of them.
And what I do know is when you have
private charity,
right,
it's very efficient,
right?
If,
if,
if you donate a dollar to a charity,
90 cents is going to go to the people
who need money.
Ideally,
we have obviously some massive
exceptions to that,
but with the government,
the government will take a dollar in
taxes and only 10 cents will go to the
poor people.
The rest of it goes to the government
bureaucracy.
And the problem with government is when
you have a private organization,
they really want to do good,
right?
I mean you have these government
antipoverty programs,
they don't want to end poverty.
They want to expand poverty.
They want,
they want more poverty because then
their program gets bigger.
Then they have more power.
The last thing they want to do is end
poverty because now they're,
they no longer have a job.
So they're not there to try to make sure
that the people who are getting the aid
actually need the aid.
I mean,
it's different when it's private money
and private charity,
uh,
you know,
there,
you're really trying to do good instead
of just perpetuate the poverty so you
can grow your power base.
Have you ever sat down with Bernie
Sanders?
No.
Wouldn't you love to,
when you love to have a debate with him,
like a long form conversation,
like a three hour podcasts?
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't shy away from it.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I do know he's,
he's sold at this point that it's hard
to believe that I'm going to persuade
him that he's wrong,
that he's going to come to his,
you know,
after living in entire life believing in
something.
Well,
I'm not even necessarily saying that you
would persuade him,
but it would be nice to see people
counter,
you know,
or hear rather the counter to his
arguments that he puts forth that are
very appealing to a lot of these young
people that you're talking about.
If you're 20 and you're not a liberal,
you don't have a heart,
you know that these,
these ideas are very pervasive in our
culture and they were thought to be the
solution to the ails that were in,
they were thought to be the solutions to
the problems with the bailout.
Why is the government getting all this
money and giving it to the banks when
they could be giving it to poor people
and,
and propping up the income inequality
like that,
that,
that conversation.
And now we're big problem.
And I knew that at the beginning because
see I was,
I was against the bailouts,
but I knew that when the government
bails out banks,
now you've created a precedent.
Wait a minute,
if you're going to bail out those banks,
why not bail out the little guy?
Right.
And I have a lot of sympathy for that
argument,
but I don't think two wrongs make a
right.
We shouldn't have bailed out the banks.
See the government shouldn't steal money
from,
from one person and give it to somebody
else.
You know,
regardless of who they're there,
they're there,
they're giving it to.
But once you create that precedent,
and of course,
you know,
a lot of people should have been allowed
to lose money in that financial crisis.
A lot of banks should have failed.
A lot of people should have lost their
jobs and they didn't.
And so that's a moral hazard because the
government created a condition and said,
hey,
if you're going to speculate and do all
these things,
you know,
we're going to bail you out.
And you know,
it wasn't,
you have to realize that it was the
government,
the government was guaranteeing all
those mortgages.
The governor was guaranteeing all those
bank banks,
bank deposits.
The government was through Fannie and
Freddie,
encouraging reckless activity,
encouraging banks to make loans to
people who they knew couldn't pay it
back.
I mean,
all this was rooted in government
incentives and government subsidies.
If there was a pure free market,
the banks would not be able to assume
all that risk.
But because the government,
you know,
had their back then they were be able,
they were able to do things that the
free market never would have allowed.
That's why for years,
you know,
while the housing bubble was going up,
I was pointing this stuff out.
I mean,
you go and you know,
look at some of the youtube videos,
um,
you know,
for all of my appearances back then that
eventually became that Peter Schiff was
right video.
Um,
I understood the,
the ultimate consequences of what the
government was doing,
you know,
but then the bailouts just,
allowed the government,
like the government never wants to waste
a crisis.
They always want to use the crisis to
get bigger,
to get more power.
We should have learned something from
the 2008 financial crisis.
Instead,
we have repeated all the mistakes,
right.
Everything that has been done by Janet
Yellen and Ben Bernakie,
since the financial crisis has actually
made the u s economy worse,
we're in much worse shape now,
economically.
So I think the crisis that we're coming
to,
the next one is going to be much worse
than the one we had to know.
Eight to get to that in a second.
But what,
what was the argument for the bailout?
Well,
the argument for the bailout was that
the banks were just so big,
right?
They were,
they were interconnected.
Yeah.
And that if we let them fail,
it's just going to be so much worse.
Right.
Cause it's just,
you know,
we got,
we,
we got to a bail amount because,
you know,
even though it's bad,
it'll be worse if we don't do it.
People like me and maybe Jamie had money
in these banks and that money would
dissolve.
Well people would have lost,
certainly would deposit of,
had lost some money.
Yes they would have.
But you know,
I agree that had we not done the
bailouts,
it would have been worse,
but it would have been healthy.
It would have been a step in the right
direction.
You know,
you,
you know,
you work out,
it's like no pain,
no gain.
I mean,
you know,
like,
we,
you've got to bite the bullet on this
and,
and do what's right.
Or I look at it like,
you know,
we were strung out on cheap money.
We were like a drug addict.
And had we just gone cold Turkey and
gone into Rehab,
yeah.
It would have been a big downer.
Right.
It wouldn't have been pleasant.
And we would had to go through all this
stuff,
but at the end of the day we could
emerge healthy instead models
being projected,
projected,
like did bid,
people look at the two possibilities,
like having no bail out and we were
looking at us here in nine years later
or having available,
well,
you know,
I don't think they,
if they looked at anything,
it was just very short term,
right.
Because all these guys are politically
motivated,
right?
An election is coming up,
right.
Because all the bailouts happened,
uh,
in,
summer of Oh eight,
a lot of big ones.
And the election was in November of
[inaudible] eight.
Right.
I remember John Mccain interrupted his
presidential campaign to come vote for a
tarp bailout.
And,
and so politicians can't see beyond the
next election.
And if your horizon is that short,
yes,
the bailouts ease the pain,
but at the cost of exacerbating the
underlying disease,
that is the cause of the pain.
So because we did all the wrong things
and o eight o nine o 10,
instead of fixing the problems and
having a healthy recovery,
we have the weakest recovery in the
history of recoveries.
In fact,
I don't even think it's a recovery cause
I think the average American is sicker
now than he was when the recovery began.
Well,
you look at personal net worth has gone
down.
Real incomes have gone down.
We've eviscerated the labor force.
I mean people have lost good paying jobs
and they now have two or three low
paying part time jobs.
People are working longer for less.
Uh,
their net worths of gone down.
They're loaded up with debt.
We now have record high cardio loans,
record high credit card debt record,
high student loans.
The only thing we don't have as record
mortgage debt.
And that's because home ownership is now
at a 60 year low.
But we do have rising rents and so our
standard of living is falling,
uh,
because we didn't do the right thing.
But because we didn't do the right
thing,
this next crisis,
as I said,
is going to be so much worse where we're
just going from crisis to crisis because
nobody has the guts to do the right
thing because in the short run it means
they might not get reelected,
right?
Nobody wants to get reelected,
promising.
You know what?
Things are bad.
We've made a lot of mistakes.
We're going to have to suffer through
this recession.
People are going to lose money.
People are going to lose their jobs,
but you know what?
Don't worry.
The free market is going to work.
You'll get different jobs.
You'll get your,
you know,
nobody has the guts to tell the truth to
the voters.
Everyone wants to pretend that they've
got,
you know,
it's like,
by my Miracle Cure,
you don't have to work out.
You don't have to die it just rub this
cream on your,
your thighs and the side lights going to
go away.
That's what people want.
They don't want to be told,
you gotta hit the gym and you've got to
stop eating junk food.
They want the miracle cream.
That's the guy that gets the vote.
So we set ourselves up for,
I think a crisis,
not just a financial crisis where were
mortgages are in trouble,
but we're,
the dollar itself is collapsing,
our money is collapsing,
prices are skyrocketing.
It's going to really hit the average
American much more than just the stock
market going down.
But when your money is going down,
right,
when the cost of living is skyrocketing,
that is going to be a big problem for a
lot of people,
that that's where we're headed.
It's ultimately going to be a dollar
crisis.
And that's really,
you know,
like my,
in my business in my brokerage firm and
Euro Pacific capital,
that's what I've tried to do is help
people protect their wealth by getting
out of US dollar assets by investing in
Singapore and Switzerland and New
Zealand and Hong Kong and other
countries owning other assets,
you know,
to try to protect themselves from this
crisis that you know is coming.
You know,
and most people are going to get
blindsided by just like they were by the
last one.
So what is the crisis and how exactly do
you feel it's going to go down?
Because I did watch some of your videos
about the housing crisis from 2008
you're predicting it years in advance.
Yeah,
I mean look,
you know,
things always happen,
I see things years before they happen
cause like you're not the only one,
right?
No.
This is something amongst your peers and
your colleagues,
you guys are all discussing this.
Well,
I mean,
I mean there are people,
oh
most people who feel the way I do maybe
aren't,
they weren't on television saying it.
They were saying it to their buddies,
you know,
in their own living rooms and they were
getting laughed at just like I was,
you know,
I guess I used to get emails from
people,
Hey,
I've been saying this is exactly what
I've been saying and everybody thinks
I'm crazy and you know,
it's just,
you know,
they're the same one.
It's everybody else.
That's crazy.
That just,
it gets caught up in it.
But what's going to happen is we are
going to go back at some point into
another statistic.
Recession.
I mean I think that we've kind of been
in one this whole recovery cause I don't
think the government numbers are really
that accurate.
I don't think that inflation is as low
as they claim at least as measured by
the consumer prices.
So I think that the economy has actually
been contracting during the years that
we've been pretending it's been growing.
But I do think at some point
statistically we will go back into a
technical recession where even the
government admits that the economy
shrinking,
right where the GDP is negative for a
couple of quarters in a row and then
what is the government going to do as a
result of that?
They're going to do exactly what they
did before.
They're going to take interest rates and
bring them back to zero from wherever
they are.
The differences.
Normally they lower interest rates and
then by the time there's another
recession their way back up,
four or five 6% this time they,
they barely got him back to 1% and they
kept them at zero for seven,
eight years,
which is unprecedented.
And of course the mistakes that are made
are consequence of money being too
cheap,
right?
The reason that we had a real estate
bubble,
the main reason was because Alan
Greenspan lowered interest rates to 1%
and left them there for about a year and
a half and then took about a year and a
half to rise to raise him back up to
normal.
So you had a few years of artificially
low interest rates and that gave us this
huge housing bubble.
Well,
we had seven,
eight years of zero.
I mean the,
the mistakes that had been made under
Obama dwarfs the mistakes that were made
under Bush.
And these are mistakes that are a
consequence of money being too cheap of
the government setting the price of
money as opposed to the free market.
You get too much debt,
you get too much speculation.
And so we've got a much bigger bubble
now and when the,
this one pops because it's so much
bigger,
right?
So then all of a sudden the Fed has to
cut interest rates again.
And now what happens to the dollar?
Because see the dollar has been rising
in these past few years because
everybody thought,
oh,
the Fed's going to normalize interest
rates.
The Fed is going to shrink the balance
sheet when none of this stuff happens.
When the Fed goes back to another round
of quantitative easing,
when they got to crank up the printing
presses,
when they don't shrink the balance
sheet,
but they bloat even bigger,
right?
It goes to five and a half trillion,
six and a half trillion.
I think the bottom's to drop out of the
dollar.
I think the dollar is going to get
killed.
The opposite of what happened in Oh
eight when the financial crisis hit no
aid,
the dollar had been falling for seven
years.
It was at an all time record low,
and then when the crisis hit,
it actually caused people to buy the
dollar.
Uh,
but I think this next crisis is going to
be the big sell signal for the dollar.
It's because people are going to rush
out of the dollar as the Fed has to go
back to more qe as people realize that
this is what I said from the beginning,
this is a monetary roach motel,
right?
The Fed checked us in and they ain't
checking us out.
There's no way to normalize rates.
There's no way to shrink the balance
sheet,
and when people realize that this is a
permanent situation,
the bottom drops out of the dollar and
then commodity prices really start to
rise.
Remember when oil prices went from like
$20 a barrel and 19 and 2001 up to 150
right?
That was happening because the dollar
was falling and as the dollar starts to
fall,
all these commodity prices are gonna
rise again and now inflation is really
going to pick up the way they measure it
and the,
the governor can't do anything about it.
They can't raise interest rates because
if they raise interest rates,
they collapse everything.
All the banks that were too big to fail.
They're bigger now,
and it would be even worse if they
failed.
So they can't let rates go up because
banks absorbed other banks,
they got bigger,
and now you have all these banks that
have all these long term loans that have
low coupons on them.
If interest rates go up,
all these big banks are going to fail.
I mean,
people think rising rates are going to
be good for banks.
They're gonna destroy the banks.
They're gonna destroy the housing
market.
I mean,
and the government,
this is the biggest thing.
Look at the national debt.
The national debt is about 20 trillion,
the bonded debt.
And that,
of course,
that doesn't even count all the unfunded
liabilities.
That's just where the government has
sold a bond,
right?
A treasury bond,
that's about 20 trillion.
But what would happen if interest rates
went to 10% well,
it would cost the government $2 trillion
a year just to pay the interest on that
20,000 on the 20 trillion we don't have
anywhere close to that.
I mean,
right now,
interest rates are almost zero.
And we're spending about 250 billion a
year on interest.
But if interest rates actually went up
because the Fed had to fight inflation,
the treasurer would have to default.
They would have to tell the cro,
we can't pay on these bonds.
What are you showing me?
Jamie's this,
the national debt.
The national debt is 20 trillion yet.
Oh,
it's so clause 19
nine seven three looking at spinning.
Oh God.
Yeah,
I know it.
Terrific.
But um,
and so obviously the Fed has to keep
interest rates low so the government can
service that debt.
Look at Medicare,
Medicaid,
Jesus Christ.
What is happening?
You add it all up.
You didn't even a billion.
Is that a trillion?
Huh?
What does that right there?
What is that?
No,
that's one point.
1 trillion.
Oh,
it is.
That's a lot of those budget items.
Those are budget items.
That's the budget.
Social Security,
that's not the debt.
That's what they're spending.
Oh,
see,
look at those numbers.
If you go down lower you,
they'll probably have all the unfunded
liabilities that page somewhere,
you know,
and then they break it down and they
break it down per capita,
per tax payer.
I mean,
it's an art,
but my point is that we've got like an
adjustable rate mortgage on that
national debt.
The government,
Scot ultra cheap money.
If interest rates spike,
there's no way that the government can
pay that debt.
This is hypnotic.
It really is terrifying.
They're seen it before.
I've never seen it before either.
That's why I'm saying Puerto Rico,
Puerto Rico,
it'd be,
it would be so idiotic for Puerto Rico
to want to join the union and absorb
their share of that debt.
Now,
for the average person like myself,
was zero understanding of the financial
system.
You listen to trump,
talk about the economy booming and it's
on an upward the thing and the
unemployment is down and jobs are up.
Yeah,
I mean bullshit.
Yeah.
That's what's really bothering me about
trump is the hypocrisy.
Because when trump was a candidate and
he got elected,
because by and large he told the truth
about the phony nature of the recovery.
Obama was out there talking about how
great things were,
and trump was like,
bs.
It's not great.
Oh,
you're talking about low unemployment.
That number is bogus.
The real unemployment rate is 20% or 25%
is people stopped looking for jobs and
it doesn't count anymore.
People are,
you know,
they gave up looking.
So they don't have a job.
They're not counted as being unemployed.
And he pointed out that all the jobs
like here,
this is irony,
right?
So what are the byproducts of obamacare?
Obamacare said that if you have a full
time worker,
you have to give him health insurance.
Right?
And full time was anyone that worked 30
hours or more?
Well,
employers aren't dumb.
They can do math.
Hey,
if I,
if this guy is working 40 hours a week,
I got,
I got to give them health insurance,
which is very expensive.
But if he works 29 hours a week,
I don't.
Right.
So what happened?
Employers started transitioning their
workforces from full time workers to
part time workers.
Well,
what happens if I'm going to have only
part time workers,
I'm going to have more workers,
Greg,
because each one is working fewer hours.
So I'm going to have to have more.
I have more jobs,
right?
If I have,
if I had 500 part time jobs,
but now I have a thousand,
I mean if I had 500 full time employees,
but now I have a thousand part time
employees,
that's twice as many jobs.
Obama got credit for all those extra
jobs,
right?
As we were,
as we were destroying fulltime jobs and
replacing them with two part time jobs.
We got all these jobs.
So trump was honest as it candidate.
These are low paying,
these are crappy jobs,
you know?
And a lot of the people that were
getting jobs were older people who don't
want jobs.
They were retired and now they're
working at Mcdonald's part time because
they can't live on their retirement
money.
And in fact,
you know,
when you look at the labor force
participation rate that he would talk
about,
you know,
we're labor force participation is
collapsing is with young people.
People in their twenties and thirties
can't get jobs.
Meanwhile 70 and 80 year olds are
working in record percentages,
right?
Cause they can't afford to retire and
their grandkids can't get a job.
But so trump was telling the truth about
how bad the economy really was.
And that resonated.
A lot of blue collar guys,
a lot of Democrats in the Midwest voted
for trump because he got it,
he understood their p felt their pain,
right?
Like Bill Clinton and Obama was in a
fantasy of an,
hillary was pretending that everything
was great under Obama and people didn't
want four more years of that.
So they voted for trump.
And also,
you know,
when trump was a candidate,
he talked about the stock market because
all of the stock market was going up
when Obama was president.
And trump said,
well,
it's a bubble.
Who cares about the stock market?
This is a big fat,
ugly bubble.
Wait til it pops.
Okay.
He was right about that.
Now he's president.
What is he saying?
Every time I see him,
this stock market's a new record high.
This is fantastic.
You know,
it's all because of me.
This is great.
And when the jobs numbers come out,
oh,
this is,
look how low the unemployment rate is.
This is the lowest it's been in 15
years.
I'm doing a great job.
I'm doing,
nothing has changed.
This is the exact same economy he
inherited.
It's the same crappy jobs.
It's the same stock market bubble.
The only difference is he's not a
candidate anymore.
He's the president and now he's trying
to market the same crappy economy that
Obama had and pretending everything is
good.
And I wish he was.
Steve would stay true to the candidate
and admit,
you know what,
the economy is still a disaster because
nothing has changed,
right?
He was gonna drain the swamp.
Instead he just poured more water in the
same swap,
let you know.
But to actually drain it means to really
shake things up.
And in a way he's shaking things up,
but not the way that's going to get
meaningful change.
For the country,
right?
The shaking up that he's doing is not
what people were voting for,
right?
We really need real substantive economic
change,
but the president is not able to deliver
it.
And he's surrounded himself with the
same cronies that,
that were around in the Bush
administration.
I mean,
what good is going back to Bush?
What,
what does his incentive to do this in
the first place?
The guys already wealthy.
I mean,
and then he gets into this position and
now he's a salesman.
Right now he's trying to sell us on his
ax and everything's great.
And under him,
everything's booming and it's going to
keep booming.
It's going to get better,
and we're going to make America great
again.
Yeah.
You know,
it was a good slogan.
And you know why?
I mean,
trump's always been a salesman,
right?
He's a,
he's a marketer.
He's his,
he makes money on his brands,
right?
So that's,
that's in his blood.
That's what he does.
And he obviously does it,
does it well,
because he became very successful.
Uh,
you know,
marketing is brand.
And so I think he's Kinda continuing
that.
Um,
but,
you know,
does he think about his legacy?
I mean,
does he want to actually a difference?
Does he,
does he care about posterity and how
he's viewed?
You know,
I don't know.
I mean,
if he,
is he just trying to get reelected to so
we can be the president again?
I don't know.
I'd have to,
I've never had a conversation with him
and I met him.
I think I only remember meeting him one
time.
I was at a concert and we were sitting
like on the same row.
He was right next to me.
It was a,
uh,
it was,
a crosby stills,
Nash and young.
And so I happen to,
and he was there with his daughter and I
think it was,
I think it was,
you know,
her fiance,
I don't think they were married yet,
but they're married now so that they
were there.
I got to say hello.
And I think that's the only time I ever
met him.
And so it wasn't really,
I didn't get a chance to engage him in
any kind of thoughtful conversation.
I know a lot of people who know him
right.
I mean,
I know a lot of people who have been in
his circle,
but they've never kind of introduced me
to it.
So I'm kind of,
you know,
I'm not really on the inside,
so I can't really,
you know,
don't really know.
Um,
but I mean,
I voted for him,
but that was why you vote for him.
Because I didn't want to vote for
Hillary now.
I knew it didn't matter cause I lived in
Connecticut.
Oh.
And by the way,
now that I live in Puerto Rico,
I can't vote anymore.
But you know,
it's like,
that's one of the things people say
that,
oh,
Puerto Rico's in trouble because you
can't vote.
Who Cares?
Everyone I voted for in Connecticut lost
in Congress.
Right.
Cause you know,
it doesn't matter.
They don't have congressional
representation because I'd rather have
no taxes and no vote then to be able to
vote for who taxes me.
But,
um,
I voted for him.
Um,
I mean,
I normally would just vote for Gary
Johnson.
Right.
I had voted for Gary Johnson before
because this is the second time you ran.
I voted for him the last time.
Um,
but,
um,
you know,
on the way to the polls,
my wife was like,
you know,
we got to vote for trump because it was
like,
he was like the best protest vote I
could cast.
I thought,
I thought he was a bigger in your face
to the establishment then voting for
Gary Johnson was,
and I didn't,
and they ran a bad campaign.
They really blew an opportunity to have
done something with the libertarian
brand,
uh,
for future elections.
So I wasn't happy with the way that
campaign ran.
And they had,
they had an opportunity there with how
unpopular both candidates were.
Uh,
but I,
you know,
I just felt,
this is the wave.
And,
and I,
I thought trump was going to win.
You know,
everybody thought that there's no way
he's going to win.
And you know,
I thought,
well,
he might lose.
I mean,
I didn't think it was 100% guarantee,
but I thought,
I thought he was more likely to win than
lose because I thought other people
would think the same way.
I knew the economy was a lot worse than
was being portrayed by the media,
by the Federal Reserve,
by Obama.
And I thought a lot of people would,
you know,
would vote that way.
And I knew the polls,
you know,
maybe not be trusted because people
didn't want to tell the pollsters that
they were voting for trump because you
know,
oh,
what are you a racist,
you know,
why you vote?
But you know,
when they get in there and vote,
they're going to vote,
you know,
their pocket book and you know,
trump was offering the most,
the,
the message that made sense.
They knew America wasn't great.
See,
Hillary Clinton was like,
we don't need to make America great
again.
It's already great.
And the average guys,
it doesn't feel so great to me.
Right.
My of living is going down.
The only thing going up is my debt.
And so they voted for trump.
But I,
I think this strategy is to blow up.
I don't like
what trump is doing.
What do you think his strategy is?
Well,
I think he is,
he has now claimed ownership of this
economy.
He has put the trump brand on this stock
market bubble.
So when the market goes down,
when the economy tanks back into
recession,
it's not Obama's recession,
it's trump's.
I mean,
he's basically taken the bait.
I think he's the fall guy.
I think the Fed,
everybody's going to blame it all on
trump.
Like,
oh look,
he inherited this great economy from
Obama,
which he didn't.
And now look,
it's a mess.
So he should not be claiming credit,
get for victories.
He hasn't won.
He should be setting us up for this
collapse that is already coming.
That is not because of him.
He needs to clean up the mess.
And it's not just Obama's mess,
it's Bush's mess.
Democrats and Republicans worked
together to screw this economy up and
the Federal Reserve was a big part of
that.
And,
and,
and trump criticized the fed as a
candidate.
All of a sudden now,
you know,
he's just,
he loves the fit.
Wasn't there some sort of improvement in
the stock market because people had
confidence that he was going to enact
these changes and he was,
well,
this is better for businesses.
Yeah,
I do think that that was able to add
some air to the bubble,
right?
I think it was a big bubble.
And then you know,
when trump won,
all of a sudden people start thinking,
Hey,
wait a minute,
we're going to get tax cuts.
We're going to get regulatory reform,
we're going to get more economic growth.
And so the market rallied on that.
But I don't think that that's actually
going to happen.
I mean,
look,
they didn't repeal obamacare.
That was a big part of the,
the,
the optimism.
It doesn't look like we're going to get
substantive tax reform the most.
We're going to get our tax cuts,
so we're not going to get a real reform
that's going to cause a lot more
economic growth.
We're just going to get bigger deficits.
We're going to lower taxes,
but we're not going to reduce government
spending.
And the real sad part is no one is
talking about making government smaller.
Everybody wants to talk about tax cuts.
Okay,
well taxes to support government.
So if you want lower taxes,
you need a smaller government.
And I want both,
right?
I want lower taxes.
But I'm not naive enough to think I can
have big government with lower taxes
because that just means bigger deficits
and deficits are a worst way to pay for
government and taxes.
So if you decide that you want to have
big government,
then you better have high taxes to pay
for it.
And you know who's going to bear the
brunt of that?
The middle class.
So if the middleclass wants big
government,
they want lots of entitlements,
then they're going to pay through the
nose.
But someone has to be honest and say,
look,
if you don't want high taxes,
then we got to shrink government.
But they're talking about making
government bigger.
Look,
trump is talking about let's spend more
money on infrastructure.
Where's that money gonna come from?
We're going to cut taxes and spend more
money on infrastructure.
You know,
we're not going to make ourselves rich
by spending money on infrastructure.
Now,
what happened with the Republicans that
voted against obamacare and now vote
against repealing Obama?
Yeah,
they're the same people.
Like what?
And what is wrong with trump's ideas?
Well,
for a stroke,
those Republicans,
again,
are hypocrites.
They only voted to repeal obamacare
because they knew Obama would veto it,
right?
So it was easy to grandstand.
Oh yes,
let's repeal it.
And it was a good talking point to get
elected,
but the minute they got elected,
they were too afraid to actually stand
on that principle because they didn't
want to tell somebody that you can't buy
insurance when you're sick for the same
prices when you're healthy.
Right.
Nobody wanted to take away that free
lunch that had been served up by,
by,
by the Democrats.
All the Republicans wanted to do is
rebrand the free lunch.
They wanted to continue to serve it,
but take credit for it.
Right.
They wanted to make it trump care or
ryan care.
Right.
I didn't even like this whole idea.
Let's repeal and replace repeal.
Don't replace with anything.
Replace it with the free market.
We don't want to get rid of obamacare
and replace it with something that's
almost the same.
It's what was the idea of replacing it
in the first place?
Because they were,
there is,
it's all politics.
The benefit was they tried to keep the
ban on preexisting conditions,
which voters liked,
but get rid of the taxes and mandates,
which they didn't.
But the two are intertwined.
You can't have one without the other.
So that people liked the ban on
preexisting conditions because they want
to know that they're covered.
If they've,
if they're going in there and they have
cancer,
they could still get covered.
Right?
But then no one's going to buy coverage
if they don't need it.
I mean,
you just cannot use what happens to
those people that do have cancer and all
these different diseases.
If we don't have universal socialist
healthcare,
how do we do this to the thing that
happens once they have the,
a lot of them have to buy the insurance
before they get the cancer,
when they're still healthy.
Right?
I mean,
I don't have cancer right now.
Right.
I may get it next year in two or three
years.
So I have health insurance now.
Right.
So if I get cancer,
I know I'm covered that that's you.
You're a successful guy.
But what about someone who's not even in
this bad position?
Like you don't have to be that
successful to be able to afford in a
free market to buy herself some
coverage.
The question is what do you do with the
person who made the mistake of not
buying insurance when they were healthy
and now they get sick?
And of course,
once you're sick,
you can't expect an insurance company to
sell you a policy because the insurance
company is trying to make money.
They only sell policies to people who
they don't think we're going to put in
claims.
So you can't go to an insurance company
when you're already sick and say,
sell me a policy.
What's in it for the insurance company?
Nothing.
So now you've got to figure out,
well,
how do you take care of that person?
Well,
first of all,
the best thing is to make sure that
person buys the insurance policy while
he's still healthy.
So that means you,
you have,
you don't have the ban against
preexisting conditions and you allow
insurance companies to sell inexpensive
insurance that doesn't cover a sex
change operation or drug abuse.
You know,
Dario,
he's Transphobic Cape.
If you just want to buy insurance that
covers like cancer,
right?
And you're 20 or 30 years old,
that's cheap.
It's very inexpensive.
It's all this other crap that they want
to mandate that makes it so expensive.
But if you get a search of a situation
where for whatever reason somebody had
no insurance and they have no money and
now they get cancer,
well that's what charities are for.
People donate money.
Hospitals,
if doctors didn't have to spend so much
time on paperwork and filling out
insurance forms,
they would have more time to donate.
I mean,
years and years ago,
doctors used to give a lot of their
spare time and of course that was before
they had the income tax.
You know,
when the doctors didn't have to pay
income taxes and when the doctors didn't
have to deal with insurance companies,
they had a lot of free time to help a
lot of poor people for free.
And doctors like doing that.
Doctors get a lot of satisfaction from
helping people.
That's one of the reason that so many
people become doctors.
It's a very rewarding occupation when
you're a doctor.
Yes,
it is lucrative and you can make money.
But doctors also enjoy helping people
for free.
The problem is they can't even afford to
do it now because there's all their time
is spent doing other stuff.
They're also saddled down by malpractice
insurance and they also have extreme
amounts of medical school debt that they
have to handle.
Yet they shouldn't.
It shouldn't be that expensive to go to
medical school.
And it wouldn't be if it was a free
market.
And yes,
if we had tort reform,
if you couldn't sue,
look,
it's funny,
you know I'm staying here in a,
at a friend of mine's house,
he lives in Beverly Hills.
We went to high school together,
but,
and so he's in real estate.
He owns a lot of property and one of his
tenants is starbucks,
right?
Starbucks restaurant.
And they just got sued and the person is
suing him as well because he's the
landlord.
So this is the circumstance and this is,
this is America.
So a guy,
and he's,
I guess he's hard of hearing.
He's not totally deaf,
but he has,
he just has a hearing problem.
And so he goes into the starbucks and
the starbucks is playing music right
there,
you know,
whatever.
They have background music on and the
starbucks.
And so he asked the guy behind the
counter,
oh,
by the way,
I'm hard of hearing.
Do you have this special device that I
can wear while I'm in here so that while
I'm in this restaurant,
I can enjoy the same music as everybody
else.
And the guy said,
well,
no,
we don't have that device.
Well,
he sued for $10,000 plus attorney's
fees.
And now he's suing my friend too,
because he's the landlord of were where
the starbucks restaurant is.
But this is America.
I mean,
you walk,
that's a hilarious lawsuit.
You walk into a restaurant and you have
a hearing problem,
get yourself a hearing aid.
Don't force the guy.
But these are the regulations.
These are the lawsuits.
The,
the Americans with disabilities act is
the most ridiculous.
I mean,
know I remember what I,
you know,
in California,
this is a true story.
I'm not making this up.
You can google this.
There was a strip club here in southern
California and I guess their,
their,
their thing was they had a shower on the
stage and so the stripper would strip in
the shower so you can watch her,
you know,
with the water.
And it was,
there was a big pole,
right?
So it was,
the shower was up in the air and you had
to climb up the pole to get to the
shower and then you do your strippers,
you'd strip,
well,
the government made them shut that down.
And it was because it was discriminatory
against strippers in wheelchairs because
there was no way for a stripper in a
wheelchair to climb up the pole.
Now,
I've never even seen a stripper in a
wheelchair.
Not that I'd spent a lot of time in
strip clubs,
but,
but this is,
this is where we are as a society,
right.
There were saying you,
you know,
if a stripper can't go on that pole,
then nobody can go on that pole.
Right.
Or if a stripper that's in a wheelchair
can't go on the,
yes.
Right.
Yeah.
Not,
you know,
but,
but all these laws and regs,
it's all this.
Everybody is suing everybody because the
government creates all these
phony rights.
I mean,
just because I'm hard of hearing doesn't
mean the whole world has to accommodate
the fact that I'm hard to hear it.
I mean sometimes people will say,
look,
let's say I happen to have a size 14
shoe.
I have,
I have a really big foot.
Does that mean that every shoe store
has,
has to stock a size 14 just,
no.
I mean cause they know that barely
anybody is going to have a size 14 so
they don't want,
but I go to the big and tall store
because I know they're going to have a
size 14 so you know,
they're going to be certain businesses
that are going to cater to people with
handicaps.
Like you know,
you have all these hotels and motels
that have to shut down their swimming
pools because they can't afford the
money to have a lift so that somebody in
a wheelchair can go into that swimming
pool.
Well,
why does every single swimming pool in
the country have to accommodate somebody
in a wheelchair?
Why can't people who have wheelchairs go
on the Internet and find out which hope,
which hotels are catering to that
particular clientele and just go there.
But when you force everybody to do it,
they were doing miniature golf courses
are shutting down because they can't
figure out how to be accessible to
people in wheelchairs,
even if no one in the wheelchair has
ever tried to play that course.
And then they end up having to shut it
down because they can't,
you know,
uh,
the whole,
the whole thing.
I used to go in,
I used to go to this beach here in,
uh,
in,
in Malibu and I was younger living here.
And in order to get to the beach,
you know,
you had to walk down like a cliff.
It was like a dog beach,
and I forget the name of it,
but there was no stairs.
You had to kind of walk down this cliff.
But you know,
in the very front there were like three
or four handicap parking spaces that
were never filled.
They were always empty and a lot of
people would have to park on pch cause
the parking lot would get phil.
But nobody would ever use the handicap
spots because nobody who was handicapped
could possibly get down to that beach
yet they had to have those spots there
anyway.
It had to have those spots,
but they didn't have to have some sort
of a real access to cause.
It's cause that's nature.
Right?
So it was a beach that no one,
no one who is handicapped could ever go
to.
But yet they had to have all these,
all these spots there.
Like you could take that to Yosemite and
say like,
Hey,
if you want to climb this mountain,
you have to have use of your arms.
So we're going to have to figure out
some sort of a handicapped access up to
the top of this mountain and is
otherwise it's unfair.
But this is where all the government,
the government thinks they're being
charitable.
It look,
do I feel bad that people have
handicaps,
are poor of course,
but that the solution is not the
Americans disabilities act.
And you know,
there are a lot of employers now that
won't hire people with handicaps because
it's now so expensive.
Whereas they would have done it before.
You know,
that's the whole thing about,
you know,
these antidiscrimination laws.
Like,
you know,
you can't discriminate based on gender,
based on sex,
based on,
uh,
you know,
sexual identity and all these different
things.
Well,
because of that,
there's actually more discrimination.
You know,
there are actually employers now who
aren't racist at all,
but who will go out of their way not to
hire minorities because they're afraid
of getting sued,
right?
Oh,
if I hire a,
a black eye or if I hire a Hispanic or
if I hire a homosexual,
what if I fire that person because
they're not doing a good job?
They could sue me.
They could say,
well,
you fired me because I'm gay.
Doesn't mean about women in tech.
I heard this argument
recently because I was reading some
article written by Ellen Pao.
She was that woman who,
uh,
had that big lawsuit,
sexual discrimination lawsuit.
She said some article about women in
tech and someone was saying,
well,
see this,
this is the reason why people don't want
to hire women in the first place.
But it isn't that sort of a slippery
slope because if she really was being
sexually discriminated against,
well,
they shouldn't really be able to do that
in the first place.
If he's saying is true that they create
this hostile work environment for women,
they shouldn't be able to necessarily
just never hire women,
just so they can remind here.
Hostile.
Right.
Does that make sense?
Remember if you have a business,
right,
right.
Because they always sue the business.
They don't.
So let's say one of my male employees
harass us,
one of my female employee,
they don't say that one guy,
the owner.
Right?
So this is how it works against him.
So more profitable because the owner has
all the money,
right?
Right.
You know,
so,
so here's what happened.
So I am an owner of a business and now
some woman walks in and let's say she is
particularly attractive.
And I start thinking,
okay,
do I really want to have this potential
lawsuit walking around my office?
Do I really want,
because maybe she really does get
harassed,
but I'm the one that's liable for that
harassment.
Right?
And I can have all the policies I want,
but you know,
guys are horny.
I mean,
we know what we're like and you know,
you,
you dangled lump me in there,
sir.
All right.
Well dairy,
but I mean 10 pete employers don't want
lawsuits.
Right?
And,
and so the easier you make it to sue,
the less likely you're going to get a
job.
So if employers are looking at,
I want to hire the person who's least
likely to sue me,
but isn't it conversely,
the harder you make it to sue,
the more likely people are going to get
harassed?
No.
I mean,
if,
if somebody has harassed and sue the
person that harassed you,
don't sue the person who happened to
employ him.
That might've had nothing to do with it.
Right?
So don't sue you,
the individual that causes whatever the
issue is.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's gotta be a pro.
It can't,
you can't just say the employer and,
but again,
when you talk about something like
discrimination,
like see I'm Jewish,
right?
So maybe it's easier if I just talk
about Jews versus something else.
But,
so let's say somebody doesn't want to
hire me because I'm Jewish.
I support their decision.
They have a right not to like me and no
one,
no one has to like Jews.
And I know not everybody does.
And if somebody is an anti-semite,
that's their right to be that,
you know,
if they want to fire me because I'm
Jewish,
they can do that.
They don't want to hire me.
You know,
if somebody wants to have a restaurant
and they want to put a sign that says no
juice,
that's there right now.
I think anybody that eats there,
I,
you know,
I think they got a problem because look,
look,
I'm not black.
If there was a restaurant that had a
sign that said no blacks,
there's no way I would eat there.
Just out of principle of effects.
I think if there's somebody that doesn't
like Jews,
the last thing they're going to do is
put that sign out there because you know
what?
They want me to eat there.
Even though they don't like me.
They want my money.
And they also don't want the blow back
and they don't want the bad public.
Can you imagine like people keep people
say like,
well,
you know,
if,
if we don't have all these
antidiscrimination laws,
then restaurants aren't going to serve
blacks.
You name me one.
Rhett,
you find one restaurant in this country
with the Internet that put out a sign.
No blacks allowed.
I mean,
that'd be the end of that restaurant.
Well,
a lot of these laws were sort of
established before the Internet was the
powerful force centers today.
Right,
right.
But we can now see all a lot of the harm
that these,
these laws have done.
Because you go back,
you go back before all these
antidiscrimination laws up,
black teenage unemployment,
let's say in the 30s was lower than
white teenage unemployment lower.
Now,
do you think we have,
we're more racist today than we were
back then.
No,
we're not more racist or less racist,
but it's all these laws that have
backfired.
All these,
you know,
uh,
antidiscrimination laws and you know,
you have this whole industry like
recently,
right?
You know,
you have this big movement because we
had the riots in Charlottesville because
you know,
they want to take down these statues,
these confederate statues as if those
confederate statues are the reason that
we have poverty and unemployment and
crime in African American communities.
These statues have nothing to do with
that and taking them down.
Is it going to change anything?
But you've got these people in America
that make a living off of poverty and
off of race baiting that want to say,
oh,
the reason that you're poor,
the reason that there's crime is because
of racism and the racism is because of
these statutes.
So vote for me,
give me money and I will help you write.
You're a victim and I am your solution.
And,
and they,
they act well,
we'll just get rid of the statute
because even if they get rid of the
statues,
nothing's going to change.
Now they have to get rid of something
else.
I think that the statute to her for a
lot of people represents racism.
Like if you see a Robert E.
Lee statue and then you read about what
Robert E.
Lee did to his own personal slaves and
oversaw some of the lashings and you
know,
in caught slaves that were trying to
escape as a horrible account.
I retweeted recently of some slave that
was,
uh,
caught while I was trying to escape.
Robert E.
Lee,
Lee oversaw that beating him and lashing
him.
Yeah,
I mean,
I don't know.
I mean all of the various stories of,
I know that Robert E.
Lee was a very well respected guy,
even in the north.
I mean he was very,
in fact,
Lincoln wanted him to run the union
army.
I mean he turned it down because he
couldn't because he was a good killer.
No,
well respected.
Well,
it was a good general,
he was a war hero in these American
Mexicans.
Also a slave owner.
Well,
so a lot of people,
so it was Thomas Jefferson,
so it was George Washington.
I mean,
a lot of people go for Neri though,
right?
Of course.
Look,
if Thomas Jefferson were alive today,
he would not own slaves,
obviously.
Right?
But if you or I were born in the
Annabella south,
if I was born in Virginia in 1750 would
I feel differently about slavery that I
do today?
There's a good chance that I would,
I mean it was the culture slavery had
been going on for thousands of years.
It's not like we invented it,
so it was horrific.
Good is that is to say,
I think you're being very honest.
I think you're being very pragmatic
about the,
my point is that most people that even
see a statue of Robert E.
Lee don't even know who Robert E.
Lee was.
The average American doesn't even know
who fought in the civil war,
let alone who want it.
I mean,
thanks to American
schools,
I don't think those statues,
those statues have been there for
looked.
Martin Luther King never cared about
those statues.
He didn't march down and said,
we've got to get rid of the statutes.
Do you know in a lot of those statues
are actually put up.
They have,
a lot of them were put up during the
civil rights era.
They were put up because people were
fighting against all the racists and so
pete,
it was a reaction.
Walls were put up.
They,
they,
a lot of them were put up in a
90019101920 I mean the southsea spike,
there's actually a spike in these civil
war monuments going up and they're
actually fairly cheap,
cheaply made,
you know,
bronze statues that were cheaper to
produce that were made during the civil
rights era and direct protest to the
civil rights era.
Yeah.
They made up these statues of guys that
grows when they forget to represented
slavery.
The people who were leading the anti
civil rights movement were all the
Democrats.
Right.
Even though lb a long time ago.
Right,
right.
Well,
this is dirt.
This is when they passed it.
When they,
when they pass the civil rights act,
1964 it was only because of Republicans
that had passed.
If the Republicans had voted for it in
the same proportion and Democrats,
it would have been defeated.
But that the part of the Civil Rights
Act that I was against,
right.
And I obviously I was a little kid then,
so I was,
I was,
I was born in 1963 so I'm just looking
back at it,
right?
That all of the,
the antidiscrimination laws that had to
do with government and the state
governments,
because you had a lot of
institutionalized racism down South by
Democrats,
right.
And all that was bad.
And the fact that we eradicated was
good.
The part that was bad is the part that
went into the private realm and said,
if you are a private person,
you can't discriminate because now all
of a sudden the government is the
thought police.
Now all of a sudden,
you know,
every,
every decision that everybody makes is
being second guessed.
You've opened up everybody to all sorts
of lawsuits and you've gotten blow back
where,
you know,
businesses are afraid to hire people not
because they're racist or bigot,
but because they don't,
they fear a lawsuit.
And so now you've increased the cost of
employing,
uh,
people that are in these,
in these specialized groups.
So I think that that was a bad thing.
And also I think legally,
I don't think the government
constitutionally has the right to tell
me.
I mean,
everybody knows,
like if somebody tried to tell me as a,
in my private life,
you know,
you need,
you need to be an equal opportunity
dater,
right?
All the women that you,
you,
you know,
you can't just date white women or
seeing this argument.
I mean,
and,
and also,
you know,
even as an employee,
right?
If I,
let's say I'm Jewish,
if I say,
Hey,
I want to work for another Jew.
I just like working for Jews and I go
and I apply for jobs and,
and I,
and I see,
you know,
I don't want to work for you.
You're not Jewish.
Oh,
you know,
so I can discriminate as a worker among,
and I can quit.
I can go to my employer and say,
you know what?
I'm tired of working for a Jew.
I quit.
Right?
That's legal.
You can't sue me for discriminating
against you and going to work for my
competitor.
So look employers or are you don't lose
your rights because you create a
business.
You don't lose your rights.
I'm sorry,
let me interrupt you here,
but don't you think there's a big
difference between someone who makes a
personal decision of where they want to
work versus someone who has power over
you?
There's a big difference that she'd
someone who chooses like I don't like
working for this guy because a,
I only like working for white people and
you can decide to do that because it's
your own personal choice to where to go
that you're not,
you're not holding any power over
someone.
These laws are created.
They're antidiscrimination laws because
you're discriminating against other
people and you can keep other people
from making a living.
Well,
employment is all about discrimination,
right?
I'm trying to find the best person for
the job.
I can discriminate based on all sorts of
factors,
right?
That's a one way to look at it.
Right?
Discrimination,
but you're being discerning more than a,
right.
What you're saying,
look,
you're going to discriminate based on
competence based on their background.
Basically discrimination,
discrimination of the word though it's
still discriminating just means you're,
you know,
you're kind of picky,
right,
right.
You're talking about discriminating
based on a factor.
Like you're being racist or sexist or
homophobic being,
being discriminating and racism are,
are different things.
Right?
Cause you,
you can discriminate based on race and
not be a racist.
Like let's say somebody decides,
okay,
I,
I can,
I can hire two candidates.
One is white and one is black.
And if they say,
well,
if I hire the white candidate,
uh,
I'm less likely to get sued if I have to
terminate him because he's not doing a
good job because he can't,
he can't claim.
So if I make that decision based on
race,
it's not because I'm a racist.
I'm trying to practically look at the
numbers.
I'm not necessarily would disagree.
They would say that is a racist
decision.
Like you're assuming that black people
would be more likely to sue you?
Well they have that statistically,
no,
because you can't,
you can't.
If I fire somebody who's white,
they can't say you fired me because I'm
white.
It's just never at,
you can't do that.
So obviously there are plenty of
lawsuits for wrongful termination.
I've had them myself where somebody
says,
you sued me because I'm black.
Nobody is going to say you fuck you fire
me.
So it is,
it is a,
a statistic,
a statistic that somebody can consider,
but it doesn't mean that they're an
actual
fantastic or more black people or black
people or rather more likely to fire for
sue for wrongful termination.
Black person is more likely to sue for a
racially based determination.
Then somebody who's white,
you know,
a women as a woman is more likely to sue
because she was discriminated based on
her sex.
A man is not likely to say,
you fired me because I'm a man,
but you're going to get someone saying
you fired me because I'm a woman because
they're a member of the,
you know,
of a protected class.
But if somebody makes a decision,
that doesn't mean that you're,
that you're,
you know,
anti women.
If you're trying to make a rational
decision,
the racism is just believing that one
race is inferior.
Just not liking somebody because cost
our member of particular,
that's totally different.
Racial discrimination should be legal.
If you're thinking about the future of
your business and just hedging,
well,
you know what?
No,
I don't care.
I think it should be legal no matter
what.
I don't want to,
Elac I think have a right
to be assholes.
Yes.
And,
but the thing is though,
if you're a businessman and you're,
and you're making your hiring decisions
based on the color of people's skin or
their gender,
and my competitors are making decisions
based on competence,
you're not going to survive.
I mean,
if you are going to turn down a better
quality female worker and you're going
to settle for somebody who can't do the
job as well,
because you want to hire a man that you
know,
you're not going to be a successful
businessman.
So I have my faith in the free market.
That racism,
there is a cost,
right?
When when you're a racist and you want
to be a racist and business that costs
you a lot of money.
And I think,
you know,
but what happens is,
the government tries to take the cost
away from racism.
You know,
they,
they tried it.
They tried to substitute laws and
regulations.
I,
I'd rather have the market punish the
racist.
Right.
Let the market punish somebody who is
hiring people that are not competent for
the job,
but he's hiring them for some ridiculous
reason.
Well,
conversely,
what did you think about the Google
memo?
Because one of the,
one of the things about that memo was
the,
the gentleman that was fired,
what does his name,
James Damore.
Yeah,
that's his name.
He was saying that Google was hiring
people based on whether or not they are
minorities and women regardless of their
competence.
Yeah.
I mean we're discriminating on like
discriminating against straight white
males to pursue people that would give
them the appearance of diversity.
Well,
they're doing that.
they're,
I mean,
they're trying to be more diverse and,
and mainly the diversity that they're
going for is they mop,
they want to hire more women and also
more minority.
So that,
that too,
but I think his argument or his paper
was more focused on the gender,
but what he was trying to do is point
out that fact that fewer women are just
in programming.
I mean,
they're not,
they're not interested in that pursuit
as much as men are.
And so,
you know,
when,
when you're,
when you're hiring,
right?
When Google is hiring and they're trying
to get the very best,
you know,
there's a much bigger pool of male
applicants for those jobs.
I mean,
it's much more competitive.
And so he's making the point that,
look,
you're just not going to get a lot of
women in these jobs.
And if you're going to just try to have
more diversity,
you're just going to sacrifice the
quality.
And you know,
I'm sure that he's right.
But the interesting thing is he gets
fired for expressing that opinion.
And what's ironic is he suing?
Well now look,
I mean look personally see personally I
think that Google should be able to,
it's their company.
I think that if they want to fire
somebody,
they should be able to do that.
Now if he had a contract,
so I don't know what kind of employment
contract,
if he's an at will employee,
you know,
I think they should be able to terminate
them for whatever reason.
Just like I think he should be able to
quit.
Well they were saying he was reinforcing
negative gender stereotypes.
That was the main reason they publicly
stated that he was being fired.
I think it,
look,
it shows you how you know how low that
we fallen as a society that you know
you're allowed to express your opinion
as long as it's the politically correct
opinion and Google is afraid of the blow
back.
And I could still look if they think
it's going to hurt their profits if they
think the way to make in America today
is to bow down on the altar of political
correctness and just pretend that things
that you know are true or not true.
Uh,
but you know,
my principals are consistent,
but I do think that they violate,
they probably violated California labor
law in the way they fired him.
Uh,
I don't like California labor law.
I mean,
I'm an employer here in California and I
don't like it.
And I would probably employ a lot more
people here if they didn't have the
labor law that they do.
Uh,
but I'm consistent in my view.
So,
but I,
it,
I think it's terrible that they had to
fire him because if he had expressed the
exact opposite position,
it wouldn't have been a problem.
Right.
It's just because he is basically saying
the truth.
I mean,
look,
why is it that you have to pretend that
men and women are exactly the same in
all aspects of life?
That there's no difference in our
evolutionary biology that men and women
didn't necessarily evolve in different
ways based on the roles that they
played,
you know,
thousands of years ago or tens of
thousands of years ago.
And that there's,
you know,
there's something about maleness and
again it's not like obviously there are
exceptions to the rule,
right?
But in general the average man is going
to be,
you know,
there's going to be certain way,
think ways that the average man is going
to be different than the average women.
And if,
and maybe men just for whatever reason
go are going into program in computer
science,
in greater numbers and women.
I mean that's just going to happen.
That's just nature.
You can't try to pretend that doesn't
exist or a bad thing.
Mary Psychology,
I mean this is,
this is something that's been studied
because looking at human beings and the
choices they make based on their gender,
based on their environment,
based on there's a host of different
factors to deny that it does seem.
Yeah.
And,
and again,
no one's talking about,
obviously there are going to be examples
that don't fit that,
that of course,
but there's always outliers.
But when we're looking at numbers in a,
in a job,
you're looking at the totality,
the,
you know,
and so if there's only 10%,
uh,
women to say,
well we need to make it 50,
50 because half the world is women is
the,
that's like if the UFC said,
listen,
we need more women fighters so we're
going to fire some of the men that are
way better fighters and we're going to
hire more women fighters to make a more
diverse lineup even though there's way
less women interested in fighting.
I'm sure.
I'm sure that,
cause obviously,
I mean I,
I'm,
I'm amazed that they're even any women
really don't want to be fighters.
But I mean obviously there's going to be
some,
but the vast majority of women that I
know,
they might like watching other men
fight,
but the last thing they want to do is
step in the ring because that's mostly a
masculine thing,
that type of violence.
You know,
most women that that doesn't mean
there's no women that want to do that.
Of course there's going to be women.
It's a good example cause they're
outliers and when you're just looking at
it without any discrimination,
you just looking at the,
this pursuit and trying to figure out
which genders are more likely to enter
this pursuit,
whether it's being a lumberjack or a
minor or whatever.
I,
you could say all the factors you want
to look.
Well,
maybe they're worried about
discrimination of other men on the job.
Maybe they're worried about being
sexually harassed me with a word about
this.
Whatever those factors are,
there's a lot more women that are
interested in other pursuits,
course nursing.
But then,
and then when the government comes in
and just says,
oh,
well the numbers are this and now we
have to fix this because this must be
the result of discrimination.
Yeah.
When it's not,
it's just the natural result of people
acting freely,
but it's also good people's response to
that.
They almost can't have a measured
objective response.
Like the woman who's the CEO of Youtube
said that she was very hurt by that memo
and that this guy was a massage.
It's the credit memo.
Meanwhile,
she's the fucking CEO of Youtube.
Like she is like an example of a woman
that can succeed.
It does succeed because she does have
the personnel.
And also,
you know,
I don't like this idea when you say,
oh I'm,
I was offended.
Right.
It's like,
hey,
you know,
you don't have a right not to be
offended.
I mean,
look,
you know,
you have to be a little sensitive.
You have to have a thicker skin.
You know,
people are gonna say things that you
offend that,
that are offensive to you.
That doesn't mean they don't have a
right to speak their mind.
You know,
people,
I mean that's,
you know,
you a lot of people now all of a sudden
freedom of speech just taken a back door
to my,
my sensibilities.
I don't,
I don't want to be,
I don't want to be offended because she
play out.
It's a cheap way out to just say I'm
offended.
And then people have to sort of act,
we ask and they have to figure out some
sort of a way to,
to,
you know,
calm down your,
your,
uh,
offended personality or your,
your whatever it is about what you've
done.
Yeah.
And you know,
no one,
as I said earlier,
I mean,
you don't have a right not to be
offended,
you know,
and there's gonna be a lot of defensive
people in the world and,
and,
and the,
and the reason that you defend,
uh,
people that are being offensive is not
because you're defending what they're
saying.
You're defending your right to be
offensive to other people.
Because look,
there are a lot of people that said,
we talked about the socialists.
There can be a lot of socialists that
are offended by the fact that I believe
in the free market or people can be
offended that I think people should have
a right to be able to discriminate.
Right.
So,
but so now if,
if I'm not going to protect somebody
else's right to free speech,
then they could take away mine.
Cause I don't want the government
determining,
you know,
what's offensive and what's not.
I don't want the government saying this
speech is protected in this speech,
isn't it?
Because the minute you go down that
slippery slope,
you know,
the next thing you know,
all the libertarians are now fascist and
none of us can speak.
Right.
And the,
you,
the government gets more and more power
and they try to shut people up that want
to criticize it.
That's truly shrinking government and
truly letting the marketplace of ideas
decide what people do and don't do and
which way they gravitate.
Yeah.
And as I said,
I think the free market and competition
will punish racist.
I think their businesses will fail.
I don't think they're going to succeed
as well as people who are broader
minded,
who are looking beyond sex and looking
beyond,
uh,
you know,
race and just hiring,
uh,
based on ability and based on,
you know,
all those other characteristics that
are,
that are relevant to the job
performance.
And to the extent that there's going to
be a disparity,
if there's going to be certain
occupations that are mostly men at the
certain occupations that are women,
it's not because of discrimination.
And in fact if you look at this nonsense
about,
you know,
women are paid like seventies whatever's
sense for every man,
which obviously that's not true because
that was true.
I would only hire women and pay him 77
cents on the dollar.
I mean,
if you could actually hire women cheaper
than men,
I mean I'm out.
Why would,
why would I even know?
Why would I ever hire a man?
I would only hire women.
I've had this conversation many times
with people that really believe that it
really believe in the gender pay gap.
There is no gender pay gap.
I mean if you,
isn't that an amazing statistic that
the,
even the president,
like when Obama was president,
he was saying that in a speech knowing
it was disingenuous.
Yeah,
no appeals
to women to get their votes.
But you know,
if,
if you,
if you basically a correct for all the
jobs classes,
right?
So if you take a woman who's let's say
40 years old,
never been married,
man,
40 years old,
never married,
basically the same educational
background and you study,
you'll find that they pretty much make
the same.
Right?
It's that when you look at the choices
that the typical woman makes during her
career and you know,
even if it's the same occupation,
let's say they're both lawyers and they
both went to the same law school,
even if they both get married,
the chances are the woman,
you know,
took a back,
took her law career and it became
secondary to her children.
She's,
she,
she worked fewer hours.
She didn't travel as much.
She got herself off that track and went
on more of a mommy track because not,
no.
Do all women do that?
No.
But more women are likely and,
and,
and they prefer that,
right?
They prefer so they don't,
they don't work as much.
They don't volunteer to travel as much.
And it's because of the choices that
they make along the way that they end up
earning less money than their male
counterpart.
Not because somebody has just
discriminating against them.
Because there is a competitive market.
I mean,
if you are a woman that is working just
as hard as a man and you're sacrificing
everything for your career and you know
you're going to,
you're going to earn the same as the guy
make us.
It's a competitive market,
especially for those higher skills.
I mean,
you just can't underpay people in the
marketplace because somebody else will
outbid you.
But it's such a convenient talking
point.
It is.
It's the lie of it's,
it's the left.
It's how you get votes.
Like,
Hey,
you're getting paid less because you're
being victimized.
You're being discriminated against.
So vote for me and I'll fix that.
I will force your employer to pay you
money.
And that's,
you know,
obviously,
there's that Willie Sutton was one of
his famous quotes was,
you know,
why do you rob banks?
Well,
because that's where the money is,
right?
So the votes are with employees much
more people have jobs then create jobs,
right?
So if you're trying to get the votes
votes of the employee,
that's better than getting votes of
employers.
So a lot of people get votes by
promising to force their boss to give
them something.
You're going to get more vacations,
you're going to get a more sick days,
you're going to get and a half he's,
he's going to have to do this.
Well,
all that,
the employer doesn't give you anything.
So if he's going to give you more
vacation is because he's going to pay
you less than wages.
I mean,
it's all a trade off.
when the government mandates certain
benefits,
all they're doing is taking your choice
away to negotiate how you want to be
compensated.
Because ultimately the employer is not
going to pay you more than you're worth.
And if you say,
well,
you got to give this person,
you know,
these vacations,
or you got,
okay,
well I gotta pay him less money so I can
give them the vacations.
It's all one big compensation package.
Well,
it seems like it's a political thing.
Again,
it's a thing that people do in order to
get you to lean towards them more and to
have you feel that,
uh,
to have people feel that this person is
looking out for my needs.
This person is looking out from my point
of view,
my perspective,
and he understands the plight that women
go through.
Whereas Peter Schiff,
he's so hardcore,
but you know,
it is capitalistic that he doesn't even
care about what women go through or
discrimination or,
yeah.
And it's like the reality is if I didn't
care about women,
I wouldn't care about these laws.
I understand how these laws backfire and
hurt women.
I understand how,
you know,
all these laws that are meant to do good
actually do harm.
And that's one of the reasons that when
you find a lot of liberals,
they actually think conservatives or
libertarians are bad people,
right?
Because they said,
hey,
you're against this law.
You must be a bad person because this
law is going to help people in their
mind you are.
Because otherwise I would support the
law.
Right?
See,
when I think about most liberals,
I don't think they're bad.
I just think they're misunderstood.
They're,
they're misinformed.
They're ignorant.
They don't understand.
I just,
they're good people,
but they're going about it in a bad way.
They don't understand that the road to
hell is paved with good intentions.
I don't want to go to hell.
I don't care how many good intentions
you have.
If I know that that road is going to
hell,
I'm going to try my best,
you know,
to,
to build a different road.
Right.
And I,
I believe that free market capitalism is
the best way to raise the standard of
living of everybody.
Whether you're a woman,
whether you're black,
whether you're homosexual,
it's the individual acting freely.
That's going to be your best hope.
If you're going to empower government,
and this is one of the things that you
don't never,
I can never figure out because people
are,
again,
they're very suspicious of,
of,
of businesses and businessmen,
yet they can have complete trust in
politicians.
You get politicians all this power and
then you trust them to use it.
But evidently,
I mean,
why aren't they just as corrupt?
Just because somebody uses politics to
get rich doesn't mean they're on some
moral high ground.
Well,
even worse.
This idea that if you give it more of
your taxes that the government is
somehow another going to going to be
competent with how they distribute those
taxes and that there's some going to be
egalitarian.
The they're gonna use the taxes for good
like that.
It's a very disgusting sort of an idea
and the idea that any sense at all
or the idea that government is going to
make better decisions for you or your
family,
then you are right.
I mean the government doesn't even know
you.
They don't know your kids yet.
You're going to,
they're going to decide,
you know what they eat or where they go
to school or you know know that the
people that care about your kids or you,
right,
you care.
I mean look at these lousy schools that
unfortunately why so many people vote
for Bernie Sanders is because they went
to these government schools and they got
a lousy education.
Their teachers a socialist.
It's all the whole socialists,
the system.
But the parents are trapped because
their taxes are already paying for these
lousy schools.
They're monopolies,
you know?
And so,
but if the Liberals Act as if,
well,
if we didn't have government schools,
then parents wouldn't educate their
kids.
Of course they would.
You don't think they would send their
kids to private schools and they'd be a
lot less expensive.
And you'd have all kinds of
entrepreneurs who are trying to earn
money,
educating poor kids,
just like people earn a lot of money,
clothing,
poor kids and feeding poor kids and,
and housing them.
I mean if there's money to be made and
entrepreneur is going to come in and
satisfy that desire,
but you against public education or do
you just think that,
what do you think?
It shouldn't be subsidized the way it
is,
like especially colleges.
Well,
I think that government education is
much too expensive and not good enough.
I mean,
people think that,
oh,
we need the government to educate.
And I think,
you know,
education is very important and I,
I don't think it's so important.
We just shouldn't leave it up to
government.
I think that the free market,
the free market does a better job of
creating computers,
right?
I think it will do a better job of
creating education and people are
struggling.
They really liked the idea that at least
education is free for the children.
It's not free.
Every nothing that the government
provides is free.
It costs money,
right?
Where's that money coming from?
The government has to take money and the
stuff that you get for free from the
government is very expensive.
The stuff that you get from the free
market that you pay for is much less
expensive and it's a much higher
quality.
Now,
you know the problem with colleges,
right?
We have a lot of colleges that are not
run necessarily by government,
but why are they so expensive?
Because the government subsidizes
university tuition by either
guaranteeing loans or directly providing
loans to students,
and this drives up the price of college.
The reason that college is so expensive
is because of government subsidizing the
cost.
So there is no free market to control
the cost.
You just have the government to
subsidize the ever escalating costs and
providing all this money.
So now you know,
people go to college and they graduate
with a mortgage without a house.
That's,
that's the government that's did that.
But you have these liberals,
they think the government is helping
them.
Like the,
the liberal,
we'll say,
vote for me and I'll,
I'll make sure you get a loan so you can
go to college.
Well,
the only reason they need a loan is
because the college is so expensive.
And why is it college so expensive?
Because of the loans.
You know what I mean?
My father went to college and his
parents didn't have any money because
they were poor and middle,
lower middle class.
Uh,
but so he worked his way through college
by having a summer job.
And that summer job was enough to pay
for everything.
Room,
board,
tuition,
and all of his friends work their way
through college.
Why can't Americans work their way
through college today?
Because the government made college so
expensive because of all this,
all the loans.
But what happened is the government
said,
hey,
you don't have to have a job while
you're in college.
We'll just,
we'll just guarantee alone,
you know,
and you'll just be able to borrow the
money.
But you know,
graduated with a bunch of debt,
doesn't do the kids any favors.
They would've been better off,
you know,
pain having a summer job instead of
like,
you know,
just partying all summer or taking
spamming their summers around Europe
while they're borrowing money.
Well,
it's two giant issues with that one.
One giant issue with the debt is you're
getting out of college and you're going
to take a job that's probably not going
to pay you a whole lot in the first
place and you're saddled down with who
knows how many thousands,
maybe even hundreds of thousands of
dollars worth of debt.
And then on top of that,
you can't even go bankrupt and dissolve
that debt.
It's the well,
his country that you're stuck with
forever.
Terrible kids take on this debt when
they're 17 1819 making good decisions.
So they're terrible decisions.
They're horrible decision.
You look,
you know,
they,
they don't understand.
They don't know anything about money.
There are two consequences.
Yeah.
And they've been fed a lie that will,
you know,
if you don't go to college,
your life is ruined.
You'll never,
you know,
I knew I,
do some of my videos on my channel,
my youtube channel and,
and one of the videos that I did and I
wish it got more views and maybe it will
be,
I could talk about on your show,
what does the Youtube Channel Tell
people?
Peter Schiff.
Peter.
Yeah.
My name is uh,
you know the shift report,
but one of the videos I did and I
called,
it's a,
is a college degree worth the cost you
decide.
And I did this like four years ago down
in New Orleans.
And um,
I went down the street and I was asking
people who were working,
I didn't talk to people who are just
there to have drinks.
I worked at the people who were working
on Bourbon Street,
right.
They were strippers,
they were bouncers,
they were petty cab drivers,
they were bartenders.
They were taken out the trash cans and I
didn't discriminate.
I asked everybody I saw and almost
everybody I talked to is on this video.
I mean,
very few people didn't make it.
And I basically said,
did you go to college?
When did you graduate?
Right?
Uh,
what was your major and how much do you
owe?
Right?
And every single person that I talked to
that was doing a menial job,
and some of,
some of them had two or three degrees,
master's degrees.
And this is all and,
and,
and the point was,
and some people thought I was trying to
make fun of the people and I wasn't
trying to make fun of anybody.
I was trying to prove a point that this
was a complete waste of time and money.
That these individuals could have done
these jobs without college.
They could have done it right out of
high school without all this debt.
And that just having these degrees
didn't mean anything.
Who benefited from these degrees?
The universities that sold these
overpriced degrees,
they benefited the,
you know,
that that's who benefits from all these
college loans.
Not these kids who borrow $50,000 and
now hour emptying trash cans because
they got some liberal arts degree that's
meaningless.
It's the universities,
the college that got the over got to
overcharge for degree that the kid would
have been better off without.
And then there's also the opportunity
cost.
You know,
you spend five or six years now and
these overcrowded colleges,
you know,
you should be four years,
but now it's so hard to get the classes
that sometimes it takes you five or six
years to even graduate and you graduate
with nothing.
You've got a worthless degree.
You've got politicians that are saying
everybody needs to have a college
degree.
Okay,
well if everybody has one,
what's it worth?
Nothing.
You know,
at one point,
maybe one in 10 people had a college
degree because,
and then it actually meant something
because you had something that not
everybody else has.
But you know,
if everybody has a degree,
then you've actually destroyed the value
of the degree.
And that's what the government has done.
They've made a degree,
extremely expensive to get,
but there's very little value.
And you have all these politicians are
not qualities.
Maybe colleges,
they'll try to say,
look at how much more money people make
who have college degrees versus people
who don't have college degrees.
And they assume that the reason for that
is the college degree.
Again,
it's false statistics,
right?
Because think about the typical person
who chooses to go to college.
They're smarter,
they're more ambitious,
they're harder working.
That's why they're making more money,
not because they have a degree,
right?
So if you probably looked at two
individuals from the same circumstances,
maybe same high school,
same demographic,
they got the same GPA,
they got the same,
uh,
you know,
sat scores.
One went to college and one didn't,
and then you followed them.
You might find that the guy that had the
gumption to skip college is actually
making more money than the guy who went
to college.
Maybe he started a business,
maybe he,
he gained some real world experience and
then he wasn't encumbered by a bunch of
debt.
Right?
So it's not the college degree at this
point.
No.
Yet.
If you want to be a doctor,
sure you got to go to college or you got
to go to med school,
but there are a lot of things that you
don't need a college degree to do and a
lot of people who were doing them have
college degrees and their success is not
a function of that college degree.
It's a,
it's a function of the hard work that
they did after they left.
College.
Education is very important,
but you can get a tremendous amount of
education today and this is not,
you know,
the 18 hundreds you can get it online.
Oh you can get it through books.
You can get it through audio course.
I mean I'm not,
sometimes I'm not anti-education.
I think people should educate themselves
and you're anti the college debt people
are,
well,
I'm anti the government saying the only
way to get educated is to have a school
do it.
I mean,
you know there are a lot of Americans we
talked about,
you know Robert E.
Lee,
but you'd go to the founding fathers.
A lot of these guys were all self
educated men.
They didn't necessarily go to college.
Some of them did,
but a lot of them were self educated.
And believe me back then,
educating yourself was pretty hard.
I mean the only books you had were the
ones that you could check out of a
library.
I mean,
now anybody,
any kid in a poor inner city has
everything at his fingertips.
You could go on the Internet and you can
teach yourself and in fact professors
can sell courses online.
You don't have to,
you know,
go to a college.
I uh,
uh,
some professor can have a tutorial site
and he could charge like,
you know,
10 bucks a month and he could give
lectures and he can teach,
you can learn all sorts of stuff without
enriching some government bureaucracy,
some college or university.
And you don't have to borrow tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
dollars to learn what you can learn for
practically nothing on the Internet.
Yeah.
Speaking to the,
I know we spent a lot of time here,
but I can't let you leave unless I ask
you this one last thing.
What are your thoughts on
cryptocurrencies,
specifically bitcoin and all these
different,
yeah,
and I know,
let's talk about that and let's,
you know,
hopefully we have enough time to really
hash this,
this subject.
How,
cause I know,
you know,
I was on your show a few years ago and
we talked about cryptocurrencies and you
know,
I was very skeptical about them then and
I'm as skeptical about them now,
but of course,
obviously had you just bought them when
I was here a few years ago.
Skyrocket,
right?
I mean,
obviously if you bought them back then
you could turn around and you can sell
them today for a lot more money,
right?
So,
but does that mean they're going to
work?
Does that mean they're going to fulfill
the promise that everybody believes?
Right?
And what is it that people believe about
bitcoin and you know,
they believe that it's going to be
money,
right?
That is going to either replace or exist
alongside of the dollar,
the euro,
the yen,
right?
That it's,
people are going to use it as a medium
of exchange that is going to be a store
of value.
And they're,
it's just not going to work.
It is not going to happen.
I know there are a lot of people that
believe this and they almost believe it,
like a cult,
right?
They believe it like a religion.
And the fact that I don't believe it,
I'm just,
you know,
I,
I'm,
I'm either a fool,
I just,
I'm stuck in my ways.
I just don't get it,
you know,
and,
look,
you know,
I've seen it all before when it came to
the dotcoms when it came to the real
estate and it's not that,
like I did a podcast again on my own and
I was trying to compare,
uh,
I was,
I was looking at,
uh,
the Internet stocks and I was talking,
I use pets.com as an example.
And I,
you know,
looked at bitcoin and then somebody did
a video critical of me trying to explain
that,
why bitcoin is not like pets.com.
And I never tried to equate the two.
What I was talking about was the idea
when pets.com was started and people
were making money because the stock went
up,
right?
They thought that the business would
succeed as a business,
that it would make a profit right now,
it never did.
It went bankrupt,
but people bought it early on and it
went up.
Now the fact that it went up didn't mean
that they were right in their ultimate
bet.
It just meant that other people made the
same mistake and paid an even higher
price.
And so you can be wrong,
but still profit from being wrong as
long as there are other fools who are
also wrong.
And that's where I see the similarity in
the cryptocurrencies or bitcoin.
If somebody bought bitcoin a year ago,
two years ago,
five years ago,
and it's now a lot higher,
it's only hire because other people are
more foolish than they were and other
more people now believe something that's
not going to happen.
Why do you think it's not going to
happen?
And what do you think are the
restrictions?
Okay,
so that's holding it back.
All right?
So people have to understand what money
is and what can succeed as money,
right?
Because yes,
dollars and euros and yen intrinsically,
there's no value there.
It's just a piece of paper and they're
created out of thin air.
But they didn't,
that wasn't always the case.
I mean,
the dollar used to be backed by gold.
And what gave the dollar value was the
gold backing.
That's why it had value,
because you can go and get gold for it
and you can convert it to gold,
but gold.
Right?
The reason that gold became money and a
lot of things have been money and the
most,
the,
what's been money,
the most successful has been precious
metals.
People have used precious metals and
gold is just spend,
uh,
the,
the most precious of the metals that has
served as money.
But the reason that gold became money
and because before we had money,
it was all barter,
right?
That's,
you know,
[inaudible] if you,
if you made a chairs and you wanted a,
you know,
a chicken,
you had to find a guy that grew chickens
who wanted one of your chairs,
right?
You had,
it was very inefficient barter,
but,
uh,
everybody wanted gold,
or at least wealthy people wanted gold.
It was a scarce item that everybody
desired.
But the beauty of gold was that it's all
the same.
You can melt it down.
You announced the gold is,
you know,
is the same as any other ounce of gold.
And people realize that,
wait a minute,
instead of me looking for a chicken guy
that wants my chair,
I'll just go,
uh,
you know,
give somebody gold.
They don't need my chair.
They can buy whatever they want with a
gold because gold is a commodity to,
it has value.
But unlike a chair,
it's uniform.
You can put it in your pocket,
you know,
and,
and they're all the same and you can
divide up.
So gold had these properties that made
it money and it was a store value.
And then,
you know,
over time there was pricing.
People could relate how much is a barrel
of oil terms of gold,
how much is a Bushel of wheat?
You can relate one commodity to another
and understand pricing,
right?
Like,
you know,
uh,
in,
in Roman times,
you know,
you could buy a Toga,
a nice toga for an ounce of gold,
right?
So a man,
a man could buy what was clothing back
then for an ounce of gold when you can
buy a suit of clothes today,
a nice suit of clothes for an ounce of
gold.
So,
you know,
prices have kind of remained relatively
constant and certain things.
So now years ago,
I guess some Libertarians and some other
people got the idea,
you know,
crypt Fiat currencies are no good,
which is true.
They're not backed by anything
governance,
keep printing them.
They got quantitative easing,
0% of the trades gold though they said
Gold is inefficient,
right?
If I got announced the gold,
I really can't use it in commerce.
I mean,
I can't scrape off a little piece of it
and buy a cup of coffee.
I can't send it across the world.
And you know,
and,
and conduct an ecommerce.
So they came up with,
someone came up with a,
a digital currency initiative.
The first one probably being bitcoin,
which was supposedly replicating all the
properties of gold only digitally and
making it better,
right?
So it's like,
you know,
you're mine,
these bitcoins,
right?
Even though there's no actual mining,
you're solving these math problems,
but you could have a bitcoin.
I can give it to you,
you can give it to me,
I can break it in half intense,
you know,
and it's divisible.
It's,
you know,
it's portable,
it,
it doesn't decay,
it doesn't go away,
right?
And so they'll say,
hey,
wait a minute,
we can create a digital alternative to
gold and use that.
People will just use this and people
will just get out of dollars and
they'll,
they'll own bitcoin and then we'll just
use bitcoin as money.
Right?
And that,
and the idea is this is going to happen,
but it can't happen because there is no
value that ultimately bitcoin has that
can be stored right.
It,
because unlike gold gold actually has
properties that,
that,
you know,
you can use gold for all sorts of
things.
People value gold for the metal.
Nobody values bitcoin for the bitcoin.
They value it because they believe that
they can exchange it for something else.
There's dollar doesn't really represent
golden anymore.
I know it doesn't,
but just because the dollar is working
as money with all the history of usage
and the fact that the government except
dollars,
his taxes,
it's legal tender that you have
insurance products,
that you have rental agreements that you
have bonds.
You have an entire global market in in
dollars,
right?
That is never going to be able to
develop with bitcoin or any other
cryptocurrency.
Uh,
ultimately the value of,
of,
of a cryptocurrency is,
is based on the willingness of somebody
else to accept it and exchange for,
you know,
for something else.
And you know,
when bitcoin first started and people
used to tell me,
well,
you know,
there's only 21 million bitcoins,
right?
You can't have any more than that.
So therefore there's some scarcity.
But my point was that,
well,
but what stops somebody else from
creating another cryptocurrency that is
identical to bitcoin?
Or maybe it's even better.
Maybe it's faster.
Maybe it has properties that maybe it
improves on big.
Just like we talked about cell phones
earlier,
somebody bakes a better cell phone.
What's your,
what's your old Motorola phone worth
today is nothing,
right?
So if somebody comes up with a better
cryptocurrency and then what's your
bitcoin worth?
But you know,
I don't think any of these,
you know,
you have like a thousand of them.
Now.
The market cap is about 150 billion for
all these cryptocurrencies and now there
are people that are saying,
look,
you got to buy a bunch of them.
You need a portfolio because she,
you know,
you're not sure which one is going to
win.
None of them are going to win.
They're all going to lose because none
of them are going to work because they,
they're there and there's no store of
value.
You know,
your people are not using bitcoins and
nor will they ever use bitcoins as a
real medium of exchange.
People use it as a speculative asset.
People buy it,
they hope it's going to go up in value.
Yes.
Can you sell your bitcoins and then buy
something with the money?
Yes.
Do you could do that with any asset.
You know,
people make a big deal about the fact
that my gold company shift gold.
We accept,
we say,
oh,
we accept bitcoin.
We don't really accept Bitcoin,
right?
What we accept is dollars,
but we make it easy for people to sell
their bitcoins to buy dollars by using a
service called a bit pay,
but they're not actually using,
uh,
they're,
they're a bitcoin.
They're using dollars,
they're selling their bitcoin and then
they're,
then they're trading dollars.
I mean,
for Bitcoin and be ultimately works,
right?
It's not going to work because I mean,
that is ultimately working.
You can use their bitcoin and you can
purchase gold with a bit.
No,
you can,
you can sell your bitcoin to buy dollars
and then you can use the dollars to buy
Bitcoin,
which meant nothing is worth dollars.
No,
no.
You sold it.
You sold your ass.
Look,
I,
you sold nothing to get dollars and he'd
take those dollars and you buy big.
No,
you sold,
you sold something,
you sold it as the big question then.
So it's something then,
but it's,
yes,
but you can sell it today for value,
but it might be worthless tomorrow.
I mean,
not right now.
It's not because somebody will pay you
for it.
So it's real.
It's the same thing as a share of,
uh,
of,
pets.com.
At one point somebody would give you a
lot of money for that stock and now
they'll give you nothing.
You know,
it's all about perception.
I mean,
there's always value in gold.
And I hear people telling me this,
well,
you know,
gold's value is subjective.
No,
it's not.
It's objective gold has value because it
satisfies a certain,
uh,
desires or needs.
It has properties that exist in the
physical world and there are things that
you can do with it.
The only thing I can do with my bitcoin
is give it to somebody else.
But I know people think,
oh,
but the blockchain is,
is so great.
Maybe it is.
Maybe the blockchain is a great
invention and maybe over time,
a lot of assets,
we'll utilize the blockchain in
transactions.
But it doesn't mean that just because
bitcoin's utilize something of value
that the bitcoin itself has any value
that is going to endure to the owner of
that bitcoin.
Especially,
you know,
when there's an infinite number of
coins.
But here's something interesting because
you know,
the idea is,
hey,
you know,
we need this digital gold because gold
can't be used in commerce the way
bitcoin can.
The irony of it is it can,
right?
There's a company and you know,
uh,
it called gold money gold money.com and
you can go there and you can open up an
account.
You should,
everybody listening should go to
goldmoney.com uh,
you can do it on your cell phone,
on your APP.
And what they do is they allow you to
buy gold.
You can also buy silver and platinum
play the amount of things,
but let's just focus on gold.
You can buy gold.
They sell it to you for one half of 1%
over spot.
Very cheap.
I've been in the gold business my whole
life.
I've never sold gold that cheap.
You own the gold.
They will have a stored for you at,
it brings vault of your choice and you
have different locations in Switzerland
and Hong Kong and Singapore and Canada.
You can pick where you want your gold
stored and now you own that gold,
right?
It's in your digital wallet.
Just like you could have your crypto
currencies in a digital wallet,
but the difference is you can take
deliver of that gold whenever you want
it.
The minimum is 10 grams of gold,
which is a very small quantity and they
will mail it to you if you want it.
But the purpose of it is not to have it
mailed to you.
You keep it in your account.
Now you can give that goal.
There are any portion of it to anyone
you want anywhere in the world for free.
I can just transfer my ownership to
somebody else.
So now there's commerce.
If you are a merchant and you want to
price your product in gold,
you can do that and I can pay for the
product using gold and you can accept
gold in exchange for that good or
service.
So it makes it so that now gold can
actually work in today's modern economy
through the Internet.
It's now is easy for me to spend my
goal.
I can use my goal to buy a cup of
coffee.
I could,
my goal to buy a car.
Right.
So I and in the short run,
right.
And I'll show you this car that I have
in the short run.
Let's assume that somebody,
is that a gold card and it's been an
actual gold.
It's made out of actually go.
Yeah.
Just real heavy.
Yes.
Cause gold is crazy because gold is a
real element.
You have a guy has wait,
hold credit card.
This is a gold mastercard.
Ladies and gentlemen.
This is a gold money mastercard and this
is,
this is heavy.
Like listen.
Yeah,
it's,
I mean compare that to just a plastic
one.
Oh,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
It's like a hundred of these.
Yes.
That is real.
Listen to this folks.
Yeah.
It's,
this is fucking gold.
Wow.
I need one of those in my life.
Well you got woke up.
We will.
We'll make you one.
I needed to get you one.
Well,
the idea is very appealing.
Me.
Let me finish this one.
This one point.
So
in the long run,
right,
I believe that we're going to go back to
a gold standard,
I believe,
and it's not just gold money,
but gold money might be the first
company to do that.
But there may be more that we'll do it
later on.
But I think that government Fiat money
does not work.
Dollars won't work.
Uros won't work.
Yen don't won't work.
But gold works.
Gold has worked for thousands of years,
but now with the Internet it works even
better.
And so I think that gold,
like through gold money,
gold money we'll do to Fiat currency,
what Fedex did to the post office,
what Uber is doing to taxi cabs,
it is the free markets alternative,
uh,
money that government can't create out
of thin air that will hold its value
over time.
And now,
thanks to the Internet,
we can be used in commerce.
But in the meantime,
right,
so I've got gold that is stored in my
gold money account.
But let's say I go to a merchant who
doesn't want gold cause he doesn't know
any better.
He just wants to be paid in dollars.
I can use this debit card,
right,
to buy something.
And is that a debit card or credit card?
Debit card,
debit card.
But it's a debit card and you can't tell
the difference,
right?
But what happens is I can spend my goal
using this card so I can sell off
basically just like you know when people
are doing with bit pay,
but I don't need bitpay,
right?
I can go to any merchant in the world
that accepts mastercard and my gold will
be sold and the merchant will get
dollars,
right?
So I can spend my gold now,
but the merchant is actually not getting
rolled these getting dollars.
But I believe in the future the
merchant's going to want gold.
He's,
once we start to get a currency crisis,
once we see the euro and the yen blowing
up,
people are not going to want to sell
their goods and services for paper
money.
They're going to want to sell it for
real money.
Now there are people think,
well,
they're going to want to sell it for,
for cryptocurrencies.
No,
they're not.
I think he's cryptocurrencies are going
to crash before the Fiat currencies.
I think they're going to make Fiat
currencies look good.
Which is unfortunate because you have a
lot of good people who are putting their
faith in these cryptocurrencies and
they're going to get burned.
And then the government's going to say,
you see,
we told you the free market isn't any
good.
You know,
you got to trust us.
You got to trust our paper money.
No,
I'm going to trust gold.
I want to trust the private sector and
if I can use gold,
why would I use anything else?
Now I know people say the knocked at the
bitcoin people say is that,
well,
it's not decentralized because somebody
has to store the gold.
Right?
Whereas nobody,
right,
of course,
because there's real value there.
But you know what brings has been
storing gold for over a hundred years
and they've never lost an ounce.
So look,
I trust banks to hold my gold,
but they're holding it in a way that I
can spend it,
you know,
back in the day,
right?
The first currencies that existed were
created by private banks,
right?
Not The government.
And so a bank would have gold.
Or actually even before that,
it was the goldsmith who would have
gold,
you know,
that he was storing and he would write
an Iou and I,
you know,
and the person would say,
Hey,
I've got gold stored at this goldsmith,
that piece of paper,
right?
Instead of going back to the Goldsmith
and getting your gold,
you can give somebody,
say,
hey look,
I owe you money.
Take this note because the gold is
there.
Th you can go get it whenever you want,
but here's a piece of paper.
Put it in your wallet.
It entitles you to that goal.
And that piece of paper could circulate
as money,
not because it has value,
but because it's backed up by the goal.
And so eventually private banks started
issuing currency,
physical paper currency that was backed
by the goal that they had.
Well,
what we're having now in,
in,
in with gold,
money is gold.
Money is like the Goldsmith.
They're storing your gold,
but instead of giving the person that
the piece of paper that you can go back,
you actually get ownership.
You actually transfer.
So if I was going to give you $100 worth
of gold from my gold money account to
your gold money account,
you're going to now have title to that
goal.
It's changing hands.
It's gone from me owning the golden,
that vault to you,
owning that exact same goal.
Now,
what's your goal?
You can do whatever you want with it.
You could take delivery of it and have
it in your hand or you can use it to buy
something else.
It's perfect money.
It's the free market money and we could
use it costless.
I mean,
it's going to be cheap.
It's cheaper than mastercard,
visa.
It's a very inexpensive way for people
to trade across borders because it
doesn't matter what country you live in.
Gold has value in every country.
You don't have to worry about the yen or
the euro or the dollar.
Hey,
I'm in Germany.
I want to sell my products.
I can price them in gold.
And Gold is not very volatile.
Gold as a relatively stable,
over time,
you can actually price a product and get
paid in gold and you can store your gold
and a year later,
two years later,
you know what?
It's going to have value.
Or You could look at the historic,
uh,
a value of gold.
So rather than trying to reinvent the
wheel,
you know,
they used to have something,
they call it alchemy.
You know,
it's hundreds of years ago.
Uh,
the alchemists tried to make gold at a
base metal and they couldn't do it.
I look at these cryptocurrencies as
modern day alchemy.
They're trying to digitally recreate
gold and they're not going to succeed.
They're just creating digital Fiat.
This is fool's gold.
Yes,
people have made money speculating on
other people's ignorance and other
people's greed,
but it's going to end very badly.
But I do believe that,
you know,
what they're doing to gold money and
what the Internet is enabling is that we
can have real money.
We can use gold.
Now in a way that you know,
our forefathers never could.
This is a real modern day gold standard
2.0 gold.
Woolworth worked better as money today
than it's ever worked before,
and it worked great in the past.
I mean,
we thrived.
America was built on a gold standard.
The industrial revolution happened on a
gold standard.
We produced a wealthiest country the
world had ever seen on a gold standard,
right?
We've become broke,
With his Fiat's standard.
We've squandered the wealth that we
created under a gold standard.
But this is a way,
you know,
when Nixon took us off the gold standard
in 1971 he said it was temporary,
right?
Well,
we don't have to wait for the government
to bring us back to a gold center.
You could do it on your own,
right?
You can put yourself,
people can now move to a gold standard.
You can earn a companies can pay their
employees using gold money.
They could pay him and gold people,
landlords can collect rent and gold.
I mean,
I hope we can have an entire society.
You know?
Right now we're being sidetracked by
this,
by this bubble in the,
in the cryptocurrencies.
But the people who are buying these
cryptocurrencies should be buying gold.
And of course what they can do now is,
you know,
if you happen to have some
cryptocurrency,
you can sell them,
you can go to gold money,
they'll take your,
they'll let you convert your bitcoins
are all coins or whatever,
whatever you got,
you know,
ether,
whatever crypto you can go and you
convert it and you can buy real money.
Right.
And then when this bubble pops,
you know,
you're,
you're not left holding the bag.
Cause a lot of people I think
unfortunately are going to end up losing
a lot of their real,
their money,
their purchasing power.
They could have bought gold,
but instead they bought,
you know,
pets.com and they,
and they didn't,
they didn't realize that that's what
they would,
what they were buying.
I'm sold Peter Schiff.
I love the car.
If you just get people to hold on to
that.
Yeah.
But I mean in their hand was like this
is a real thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
and always complained about the loss of
the gold standard.
I mean,
that was,
that's a longstanding complaint.
You go back to the constitution,
right?
Gold is money.
In the constitution.
It says that no state shall make
anything but gold and silver coin,
legal tender payment of debt.
The federal government is only given the
power to coin money.
What are they coining?
Gold and silver.
I mean that that is,
is the standard that you know,
we have,
you know,
the first time we mentioned the civil
war,
the first time we ever had paper money
in America was during the civil war and
the,
the union issued it,
but it was,
it was the greenback.
It was backed by gold and when the war
ended,
they stopped issuing them,
but they issued it based on an emergency
wartime power.
It wasn't that they had the right to do
it legally.
They said,
look,
it's a war.
We need to win this war.
And so that's the first time we had
paper money.
Then it went away.
It didn't come back again until 1913
with the Federal Reserve.
Is it really possible that this can make
a return?
What can,
that gold standard can actually be
something that we all go off and I am
convinced that we're going back to a
gold standard,
but I think the free market will lead
the way because if people start
rejecting government money,
right?
If they start rejecting the dollar,
if they reject it,
Europe,
they reject again.
Then what does the governor going to do?
I mean,
the source of the government's power
really is the money they spent.
That's where they,
they buy their votes and they peddle
their influence.
But if,
if individuals and merchants just start
saying,
no,
I don't want that paper money.
You want to buy my products,
pay and goal,
right?
You want my services,
pay me in gold.
And if more and more people start opting
out of that system and just start
working in a gold back month,
which we know works,
but we don't need the government to make
gold money.
Gold was money long before the
government came around.
What the government did is when they
took over money,
right?
That's,
you know,
they,
they would debase it,
right?
That's where the term comes.
Because the government would start,
they would make gold coins and they
would stick copper in there.
Other metals because they would try to
create inflation.
But when you had private money,
you know,
it was,
it was gold.
And so we don't need the government.
The problem is these cryptocurrencies,
they're being marketed as the private
sector's alternative.
It's not gold is the alternative.
But we now have,
we,
you know,
we now have the method of,
of using goals,
right?
Cause I,
when I have this,
this in my wallet,
right?
I can carry,
but I can carry,
I,
if I have a $100,000 worth of gold,
I have $100,000 in this wallet.
It's here and I can use it to buy a pack
of chewing gum.
I could use it to buy a flat screen TV.
I can use it to buy a car.
Right?
So I can buy tiny things with it.
I could buy expensive things with it.
And here it is.
I'm carrying it around,
right.
And I can use it through my,
my,
my cell phone.
I could take my cell phone and pay for
stuff and ownership of my gold will
instantly transfer to a third party.
And of course if you want to gift money,
if I want to give money to my kids,
I can give them gold,
then they can spend it,
right?
They can spend that using their debit
card or they can directly spend it.
So this is the real ultra,
this is what these cryptocurrencies are
promising to be.
But they never will be.
But I think a lot of people are getting
greedy.
A lot of people think,
oh,
these things are going to be worth $1
million a piece and you know,
pie in the sky.
And it's like that greed overwhelms them
and they can't think rationally.
You know,
in anybody that doesn't agree with them,
doesn't get it.
And I had the same mentality,
permeates every bubble.
People can't think rationally.
And you know,
as the price goes up,
you just become more emboldened in what
you believe because you're getting
rewarded by the market for your mistake.
But you don't think it's a mistake
because you're getting rich and you're
looking at people like me.
Hey,
look,
y'all,
you know Peter,
he's not buying.
You.
Look at all the money he's not making.
He's a fool.
He should be buying these
cryptocurrencies so you know there's a,
there's an old expression to don't
confuse brains with a bull market.
There's certainly a bull market in
cryptocurrencies.
I think it's a bubble,
and I think that people who are making
money,
some of them are going to get lucky,
right?
Some people are going to cash out and
they're going to make money,
but the money that people make is going
to match the money that people lose
because you're going to have a lot of
people who are going to come in late to
the party.
They're going to buy and they're going
to be left holding the bag.
Now,
of course,
there's going to be a lot of losses that
aren't real money.
Let's say somebody bought bitcoin few
years ago and they paid $1,000 and now
it's worth 100,000 but they haven't sold
because they think it's going to 10
million,
right?
If it goes to zero,
all they lost was a thousand right?
Even though it was worth 100,000 but
mentally they lost a lot more because
they thought they had all this money,
right?
And mentally they got used to have ela
and it's going to be even more so
there's going to be a lot of dreams that
are going to shattered,
right?
Cause a lot of paper profits are going
to just go to money heaven because
they're just not going to be there.
But ultimately the only real money
that's going to be made is by the people
who cash out.
Cause because this is just a,
you know,
a self generating Ponzi scheme.
It's all about you know,
needing new people.
And that's why I think a lot of the
people into the cryptocurrencies,
they get so upset when somebody like me
doesn't get it because they need more
people.
They need a bigger market,
they need more buyers.
To come in to keep paying a higher price
to keep it all going.
And so if somebody comes out and cause,
you know,
say the emperor has no clothes,
because if a lot of people decided they
wanted to sell their cryptocurrencies,
the price would collapse.
And then what would happen?
I mean,
what happens if bitcoin goes from 4,000
to 1000,
how do you now make an argument that
it's money?
How do you,
how do you console the people that
bought it at 4,000 and now it's at 1000
and then what if it goes to 100 and then
what if it goes to zero?
Now,
you know,
there was a time bitcoin went up to a
thousand and then it went down to 200
and then it rallied.
So now people are convinced,
okay,
well if it sells off,
it's just going to rally back.
What if it doesn't?
It doesn't,
it doesn't have to come.
They can keep on falling.
Especially since there's so many,
uh,
cryptocurrencies now that compete with
Bitcoin,
right?
I,
I've said,
you know,
how many people search on,
uh,
on yahoo versus Google?
I mean,
yahoo was before Google or how many
people are on my space today,
right?
I mean,
you know,
no,
people aren't on facebook.
So how do you know that,
that uh,
that bitcoin isn't the,
the myspace of cryptocurrencies.
But again,
I don't think any of these
cryptocurrencies will work,
but I do think they will work at,
they backed them by gold.
You can have a cryptocurrency backed by
gold.
The only problem there is the government
won't like that because that'll work so
well that the government will shut it
down.
The government will go.
And so that's why like how will they
shut it down?
Well,
they might say there's money laundering
going on,
you know,
but that's why gold money,
see gold money does all the know your
customer.
They know all the k you kyc.
So when you open up a gold money account
and you own physical gold,
they do make sure they get your photo
id.
They get all this information on you.
So they're,
they're d,
they're complying with government rules
and regulations.
So there's no,
there's no,
nobody's extorting money using gold
money.
There's no criminals.
I mean that is where,
and I've,
you know,
people have argued in the,
I've pointed out that yes,
the one place that bitcoin seem to be
used as money is in crime,
right?
If I was going to blackmail you and I
was going to threaten to shut down your
podcast,
unless you send me some money,
I can demand payment in bitcoin.
And the reason I'm doing that is because
of the anonymity.
I think that,
you know,
I can get away with the crime and I
don't care if the bitcoin loses 20% of
its value between the time you give it
to me at the time I cash it in because
criminals are used to paying to launder
their money.
They just want whatever they get is
gravy.
But you know,
if I'm a merchant and I'm selling,
I sell gold,
right?
I sell gold and my margin and my gold
business is about 1% so if I sell gold
for $10,000 I bought it for 990 right?
I have a little bit of profit.
I can't afford to do that business in.
I mean the bitcoin can move 2% I wiped
out all my profit and I've lost money.
I need something that is very stable.
But if I'm a criminal,
just extorting money doesn't matter.
So it can work for criminals,
but that's where the governments could
crack down on it.
All right.
I gotta I gotta wrap this up.
So if people wanted to get involved in
this,
what would be the best resource for them
to get information?
How to get started?
Well,
they should go to the website,
goldmoney.com just open up an account
online.
And the beauty of this is to,
and you could do this yourself,
they have a referral program that as you
refer people,
you send them your own link.
So once you open up your gold money
account,
you get a referral link and now you can
send it to your friend.
And now if they open up an account,
you get some free gold.
So you actually get paid.
And,
and,
and so as you educate people,
it's kind of like a marketing.
But they will compensate you in an extra
goal.
And so,
and when you open up your account,
they'll give you a little free gold.
You get a little free gold for referring
somebody to sponsor it on this podcast.
You should be a little bit of free
google.
Yes you can.
I mean,
in fact the number of people that you
have on the podcast,
you can get a lot of free goals.
It seems like you could have a big ad,
like our whole podcast was a big,
a big fake ad for Frigo.
Yeah,
well it's,
well,
it's really for the concepts of freedom.
Gold is economic freedom,
right?
I mean that's like even Alan Greenspan,
that was the title of his essay.
Gold and economic freedom.
But it is,
and you know,
the more people that we can move into
their own personal gold standard,
the more people that can save in gold.
And the beauty of like a gold money
account.
You have your money in a bank account.
What if the bank fails?
You know,
this money is banked.
Your gold is bank,
but you own it.
It's not being loaned out to anybody.
It's in a storage facility with your
name by breaks.
So you can spend it.
When you put your money in a bank
account,
they loan it out to somebody you know.
And you know there's government
insurance,
but so what?
They just have to print a bunch of
money.
You're,
you can bank your gold without having to
put it into the banking system.
There's no bail ins that you have to
worry about.
Or Bank failures.
You don't have to worry about inflation.
It doesn't matter how much money the
government prints,
they're not mining any gold.
Gold is going to maintain its value.
So to the extent that you don't spend it
right away,
it's going to gain value between the
time you deposited or the time you earn
it and the time you go to spend it.
So it's a great store of value.
But thanks to the Internet,
it is the best medium of exchange.
It's cause it's so easy now to do it so
you can get out.
You know,
you could promote it.
The people that listen to the podcast.
I mean,
and again,
there are other people that say,
oh Peter,
you know,
you don't like bitcoin because you,
you're promoting gold money that,
you know,
I,
if I thought bitcoin was going to work,
believe me,
I'd have been all over it.
Right?
I mean,
I have a person,
a very high principles and standards.
You know,
I started selling gold long before I had
a gold company.
I used to tell my brokerage accounts at
your Pacific capital.
I would tell them,
look by some gold and I would just send
them,
does it go buy it?
I didn't sell it.
And the money that they use to buy gold
was money I couldn't manage.
You know,
I'd make money managing money for fee or
commissions.
And if people took their money and
bought gold,
I wasn't making any money,
but I thought they should buy it because
it was the right thing to do.
And I got involved with gold money
because I,
that they were onto something.
I thought that they were doing something
big.
It's more than just about money.
It's about a crusade to take back our
freedom,
which I think Berlin,
uh,
begins with money taking the power away
from government is rejecting the source
of that power,
which is the money they spend to corrupt
the economy.
So to the extent that more and more
people,
I mean,
this is the most important vote.
It doesn't matter who you vote for in
the,
in an election,
vote with your feet on the money,
vote away from the Fiat based system and
vote in favor of goal.
Right?
That's the,
that's the monetary system that our
founders believed in.
That's what was embodied in the
constitution.
And that's what worked.
And you get to that sweet car that's
made an actual,
the sweet card feel good.
Yes,
you get,
you can get a plastic card for free.
Oh,
I want that.
But you have to pay for the gold card.
But the beauty of it is it's worth its
weight in gold.
So even though you have to pay for it,
you own that gold.
It's worth it.
Yes,
because it's actual gold.
You can melt it down.
It's good to have.
Yes.
I mean you need to have one in my life.
People have,
people have to understand who you want
to.
You want to let me hold it one more
time.
One a hold of Jamie.
Yeah,
I feel that.
Feel that there's not that many people
that have those,
but feel that that feels legit.
Doesn't it actually better than a black
card?
Wait,
yes.
Way better than black.
And you know what an Asshole,
they actually have all the cost shares,
you know,
they,
they sign up to,
you can get all those benefits to oh,
like to chant with American Express,
they sign you as yes,
they have the cost shares.
They have all those programs.
So you don't give that stuff up.
You just have,
you just have real money,
you know,
behind.
You're just have to make sure that if
you throw it into a restaurant that,
that you get it back.
I like it.
Listen,
we're going to come back next time
you're here.
Hopefully this will have taken off and
you can,
uh,
you could say,
see I told you.
Yes.
Thank you so much,
man.
So it was three hours flew by.
I,
we started late.
It hasn't been three hours.
Yes,
we're good.
All right.
It was amazing.
Thank you
so much.